hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I just check it in on you we're
recording this thing I don't know what
I'm gonna put this out I might just do a
special episode because I'm now I'm
already thinking that people are gonna
be like well how come you didn't talk
any Stanley Cup final [ __ ] action
here I have with me what am i one of my
favorite people one of my great friends
in this business since the late [ __ ]
90s he has a new documentary coming out
on the all things comedy Network about
the amazing Jonathan called always
amazing the wonderful talented mr. Steve
Byrne thank you thank you William
he like that can you follow that intro
did I go too big I think you you hit the
sweet spot and I gotta tell you I was
think about this all the way over you
are part of the two greatest events I
ever had because I grew up playing
hockey and all right you and I played
you can actually play I'm fun to skate
around I mean I look good at this you
can play we played at the United Center
together in Chicago yeah and we had the
whole rink to ourselves and then you and
I got to play in the Mario Lemieux
fantasy camp well back up Vince Vaughn
set that up the big Chicago guy yeah
and I'm in business with Vince doing
efforts of a family sure because of you
because you you introduced me to Vince
why remember he oh god I remember when I
it was like when III kind of mu I think
you had just moved here or something
yeah and I was down the improv and he
had come out to see you set and you
actually most la people would try to
horde that connection be like this this
a list movie star is mine right and you
were like hey man I'm doing a spot
tonight if you want to come down on the
show you asked me because I wasn't even
on that show you said I'm bringing Vince
down you should meet him and say hello
yeah and through that I took a meeting
with them and that's when I was totally
disgruntled it's weird I'd moved to LA
and I was completely over Hollywood
because I could never get anything and
you had just moved here yes
didn't take too long that's me that's a
no-no I was already over it I was just
like I'm coming out here and I'm just
gonna do parts on other people's things
because my things do not get picked up
and then you get into a deal and then
they just take you all day it takes you
out of play well he's in a deal we can't
he you know we would be second position
to his project and no one wants to be
that so then your pilot wouldn't get
picked up you weren't in anything and
you just you were another year older so
I was just like [ __ ] this
yeah so that's when I took the meeting
with Vince's company with Peter
Billingsley and he goes what do you got
and I go nothing what do you got and he
was like all right I go dude none of my
[ __ ] gets picked up everything's
considered misogynistic homophobic
[ __ ] something else faux Baker saying
it they're probably going ding ding ding
I'm in the club yeah and it's just like
every [ __ ] thing that I do is like
was labeled so unless I had a it's it
get gotten to the point this is pre me
too
sure yeah it was like what if I had a
guy come out with his junk tucked
between his thighs okay we like that
it was so [ __ ] mean this whole
[ __ ] thing that they say women don't
have power in Hollywood
III never met him I met one or two male
casting directors I never got to that
level of you know the Harvey Weinstein
guy wanting to watch you take a shower
whatever [ __ ] level that is I know
what you watch him take a shower I never
got to that level I never did dude
casting director I'll tell you this when
I first moved here I never forgot this
because I think you and I somewhat have
an Irish temper but I got oh yeah dude
I'm going to therapy for my temper right
after this I got a Korean in Irish too
so the you know the Koreans are the
Irish of Asia is that real yeah cuz you
know it's like it's we love whiskey
we were fighting we love we love booze
and we love storytelling where the
funnest ones to hang out with in Asia we
love potatoes and cabbage we hate the
Sun it's like all these other Chinese
and Japanese people agree with this that
they they have to give it up to the
Koreans yeah yeah hey pop entertainers
are always the big ones there you know
it's all the Asian stars or would you
say you have the most flavor as the
young kid saying it's I can't even say
that you've never heard like even like
Melinda I cringe what I have to say that
it's like can I just say Timberland but
a boy always when I first moved here I
was driving to this audition and this
this [ __ ] [ __ ] in this Mercedes
would not like like let me through
whatever and then finally we get to this
light and she's jockeying for position
I'm jockeying for position where get off
the 405 we go to this light and I just
roll mine on when I'm like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and she goes [ __ ] you so
we're ten minutes later I I sign in the
audition I sign in everything I open up
the door
she's the casting director oh no I just
go I have a good day and I just shut the
door got my car and I was like did she
recognize you oh yeah yeah she knew is
she knew and I knew as soon as I opened
I just like I just looked at I was like
[ __ ] yeah but you know something I loved
that you owned it and didn't [ __ ] do
the audition cuz my dumb ass would have
done it I'll be like hi I would have
gone through with the wacky next-door
neighbor Hey Dude talk more about some
of the like Asia stuff because it's
never covered over here and I did some
gigs over there and was like fascinated
where I literally felt I went to an
alternate universe where you go over
there there's first all this way more
people it's this entirely different part
of the world that is doing just fine
without [ __ ] Western culture or any
of that and when we never talk I go over
there that the own Airlines own doctors
a whole [ __ ] thing like you you grow
up like reading our history and you feel
like in less than less you know
Europeans or yeah or are you white
Americans somehow have their hand on it
it either doesn't count or it won't work
or what happened I went over there and I
[ __ ] loved it I felt like I went to
another planet yeah just the cars are a
little smaller and the vending machines
are a little shorter but they get but
you go over there you know this is like
the perfect example right so it
Hollywood's been around forever and then
they have crazy rich Asians right and
it's sellable like it's a good movie
right I don't think it's great like the
same way I think Black Panther is it's a
good movie I don't think it's amazing
it's not I was doing a bit on that how
it scared white Hollywood was that they
nominated that for Best Picture it's a
guy
was good it was good I don't think
that's up there with the Godfather and
raging hallways yeah no no comes out
there's like oh my god isn't this great
didn't we do a good job and then you
know where that movie bombed [ __ ]
China because they're like yeah guys we
do this [ __ ] all the time no I have
incredible movies over there yeah cuz
Bobby Lee Bobby Lee told me like I had
to stop asking Bobby Lee because Bobby
Lee just watches Kirk he's the one who
told me about old boy old boy yeah yeah
and then he the audition additions great
it's it's disgusting and yeah Ichi the
Killer and all that stuff it's all it's
not scary as much as it's just
disturbing and very disturbing yeah like
you can't kind of shake it so don't if
you already [ __ ] up there they're
there no people listening gonna watch
him but yeah but this is what how my
little under staying agent it seems like
Japan is the white people of Asia where
they feel like they are the top of the
food chain and they are the everything
that they do is the greatest and they
try to take everybody over but that also
seems because of them geographically
they're on an island and they're kind of
like they've kind of like think they
can't go out anymore
yeah what's [ __ ] up about them is do
you know they had a war with Russia last
century and one and when they claim
their land all the white countries like
nah
give it back that's sort of the prequel
to them Pearl Harbor on all of that like
because anytime a white country would do
that to another white country another
white country you got the spoils of
victory and they won yeah it was like
they played for [ __ ] USC with Pete
Carroll like Nana Nana give me give me
give me that Highsmith trophy back give
me what are you talking about dude I got
[ __ ] yeah I ran for those yards na
nananana yeah I think like Koreans are
you know China like like we think like
you know we spent time in New York City
obviously an you think Manhattan New
York City you know if you can make it
there you can make it you go to any of
these cities like you go to Beijing you
go to you know anything in check it's
like it absolutely dwarfs Manhattan
Manhattan is absolutely it's almost like
Manhattan becomes like a block
comparatively to these other cities or
Hong Kong was like that you always
driving to the airport I was seeing
clusters of Manhattan it seemed like
that were apartment complexes now dude
let's
to be honest here it's an environmental
disaster over there as far as how many
[ __ ] people there are of course yeah
yeah great people not saying anything
bad about them but that you need to get
rid of like I don't know how many it's
got the numbers got to come way the [ __ ]
down
this isn't like when they had the
Olympics over there and like China and
like nobody could move for three days so
all the dust would settle it down and
then they they said they sent out those
Rockets to to like disperse the clouds
so that you could have Sun - to get rid
of all the smog yeah I always over I was
crazy yeah and this is that's what well
that's what the [ __ ] but their head is
broken and leaving the car run and and
just like that Papa Papa 70s truck you
know the guys there's got to be a better
way I think eventually I think they're
up against it and they're gonna figure
it out that's what I'm hoping they're
gonna be forced to at some point yeah I
think at that point where if nobody
couldn't lift you have to shut down a
host city just to get a clear day yeah
you would think now there's the thing
that I heard about the reason I China's
population got the way it was was Japan
kept attacking them and then whoever
their leader was his whole thing was
we're gonna have so many people that no
matter how many you attack there's
always gonna be another hundred thousand
coming over the hill like this
never-ending Braveheart now is there any
it's like [ __ ] their way to supremacy
like you can't [ __ ] with us now let me
is there any truth to that and I'm and
this is so ridiculous that you're
American but because you have your half
Asian that I feel like you know all of
this I didn't go to Kent State
University in Ohio and studied like the
history of Asia
I barely know what I know about my folks
you know so what you went to school I
went to Kent State yeah oh yeah did they
have like a little memorial shrine
that's why those kids got a get shot
right yeah yeah I was there for I forget
I think it was like the 25th anniversary
so I don't know which did you ever have
the balls to protest anything on that
campus did you just think it or did you
feel like it's more like if you fly in
the same airline that had a plane crash
the day before you like what are the
odds like what are the odds of national
guards gonna come in and blow away some
more students here yeah but I got bad
luck it would be like oh you know the
odds are astoundingly incredibly against
me why is that I think it cuz I remember
when your fees law no but you were one
of those [ __ ] guys you do a late
night set at the comics
strip and everyone would have a tough
time yeah but you somehow would have the
crowd where the guy picks up the chair
remember he threw it and hit you in the
head you got cut cuz I remember they put
staples in your headshot at the comic
strip make make it seem like you had
stitches yeah then then somebody wrote
underneath my head shot it said the
chairman the Chairman Steve Byrne I
don't know I remember that night I was
at the I was at the comic strip and this
is like another thing I do that's
probably stupid but I take the onus
always on myself right and I always say
what could I done better that situation
and what happened was I was my birthday
dude it was my holiday and I'd work on
this bin I was so excited to you know
was like that at that time or your life
read just like I just got to try this
bit out right and went to the comic
strip 11 o'clock late night and there's
all these like Jersey mooks and they
they stand up and they're there debating
their check while I'm doing my set in
front of ten people yeah
and uh-oh guys come on we just keep it
down I just want to go through this and
the guy goes what do you can do some
kung-fu on me oh okay okay oh you went
you went racial and then early I was
like early it's always I go well thank
God the the Lincoln tunnels open 24
hours and then his girlfriend starts
piping in and everybody chants [ __ ] at
me and Jackie Chan to call me Jackie
Chan this is when I had my Lego head
hair when I was just growing out and you
guys were [ __ ] Oh Matt the seller
for for this bouffant of like Asian hair
so you were kind of asking for it I was
asking for it was like man I might as
well go on stage dressed like a
leprechaun everybody think they're gonna
say so this girl starts piping up and
she goes she said something about me
being a IJ I just go well somebody did
somebody tell that [ __ ] to shut up I
know this and then this this barstool
gets chucked whizzed bang hit the back
of my head it just felt like hot tea
running down my neck huh
and eight staples in the back of my head
later and I the cops came to visit me at
the hospital like you should press
charges and I was like I did it I should
have I should have handled it better it
wasn't amazing though like how different
that time what year was that that was
probably 99 mm how different the world
is now where there would be all of this
oh yeah you would be considered this
victim of racial hate I hate crime yeah
you your Twitter followers would have
gone up by half a million you would be
like you'd be an arena act but now I'm
an outcast but then no but but back then
back then it was just like if you were
Asian you had to take the fact this a
Jackie Chan when did you go [ __ ] go
run with a rickshaw you wouldn't deal
with all that is then and then and
they'd throw his stool at you what you
wanna know this this happened at The
Comedy Store it's always racial with the
Comedy Store remember the dark days at
the store and nobody was going I don't
know if you had been oh yeah no it that
and and I guess like something out of
all like cuz everybody says New York if
I can make it there I can make it
anywhere
la is infinitely harder because the
thing about New York was I felt I could
escape the business where it was just
like my neighbor was you know whatever
was his financial [ __ ] or or worked
at a gym or like my roommate like he was
into hockey and [ __ ] worked at the
rinks in in Central Park he was in a
completely different [ __ ] world
here's an Irish immigrant and he's
[ __ ] doing construction yeah over
here it's just everybody is this [ __ ]
thing in this thing and then there was
also like the hierarchy where it was
like as bad as New York was I wasn't
competing with television and movie
stars who were popping in and and and
they would go in and have nothing to say
and burn the light for 90 [ __ ] minutes
as you sat that bombing because because
they have a TV credit well I was at the
store and again maybe 10 people there
and this group of Asian kids gets up and
walks out as I'm walking on the stage
and being introduced and there's this
dude in the back with four of his
buddies
he's eating chicken wings he brought his
own wings in right uh-huh and before I
even hit the mic he goes eh your friends
left he says it he's eating chicken was
he doing that was a fingers licking a
saw something a [ __ ] infuriated me I
go you see you're saying my friends left
because I'm Asian and they're Asian he
goes yeah that's what I said I go well
maybe I
you go outside and catch up with him
maybe you should meet me he goes maybe I
will so he gets up and I get up and I
you know that you know the one she sent
I didn't even start it I didn't tell one
joke I get to the corner this is when I
was I would get hopped up zero to sixty
and I just [ __ ] like drill this guy
in the face to drop to the ground and I
just start [ __ ] wailing I'm like
Ralphie in a Christmas Story I'm [ __ ]
beatin the [ __ ] at and this guy I didn't
know this this guy picks up one of those
tables in the back you know how those
things are he goes to like swing and hit
me with this table thank God Bret Ernst
saved my life I'd probably be eating out
of a straw in a [ __ ] wheelchair right
now but he he tackled the guy and took
that guy out and then I think one or two
other comics came in and subdued their
other friends and then they pulled me
off the guy and the guy called the cops
the next day and was gonna threatening
to sue and everything for what exactly a
fight and then Tommy said didn't you
make fun of him for being Asian he's
again and then he backed out so that
that kind of happened Jesus man yeah
well let's talk about your movie Steve
now I see why you went behind the camera
here on this one give yourself a break
from these MMA matches yeah that's it
I've been on the other end of things too
but yeah yeah
oh I remember yeah you were you were
having a cab drive you were getting a
steak and cheese and next thing you know
you had a broken jaw at a broken jaw
yeah and then they had to shut down
Sullivan & Son for like six weeks yeah
anytime anybody breaks their jaw I go
six weeks an athlete Sidney Crosby broke
his jaw they actually Sidney Crosby
broke his jaw the day I broke my jaw
that's how big a Penguin's fan you are
yeah that kind of synchronicity it's
like when women's periods line up it's
the same thing you and Sidney Crosby
tooth were syncing up ya know the film
is always amazing it's his documentary I
did about the amazing Jonathan great
comic magician that was one of the first
comics to pop off at Comedy Central when
they did those half hours and they were
starting to really get some notoriety
and Joe I saw that guy from way way back
in the day like he liked that I am such
a huge fan of that guy and if you never
saw the amazing Jonathan he felt like he
was the first guy who really
I did that whole thing where he you just
kind of see that it wasn't about the
trick necessarily was about the trick
going bad and but he added a whole new
like sort of spin to that where he had
like the whole rock-and-roll look and
Krueger comedy yeah he looks really like
he did look like you didn't know what
the [ __ ] was gonna happen I loved him
yeah he's definitely like more of a rock
star but definitely more of a comedian
than a magician and you're right like
everything he did you could almost kind
of see it and then sometimes the tricks
would go bad but he just didn't give it
like yeah he was just kind of like this
makeshift kind of comic on the fly
involved in magic and I he was one of
the when I when I first went on the road
I did back-to-back weekends at Charlie
good nights back in the day and my first
week was Brian Regan and the second
weekend was the amazing Jonathan and I
struck up a friendship with him in his
road manager Joel Osbourne who's a huge
Oasis fan and we just bonded over that
so every time I came out here our first
TV court it was beat he's comicview
and I crashed it Jonathan did I think
two or three but sorry when I think of
my first TV set I think a comic you and
then celebrating with those guys and you
know Jonathan went on Vegas headliner
and he was given a terminal diagnosis
due to cardiomyopathy where it's a
degradation of your heart breaking down
and his heart's operating I think it
like 60 to 50 percent capacity right now
so Wow
that combined with a lifelong drug
addiction and the fact that he's still a
drug addict and diabetes compounded upon
that Jesus was told you got you got to
get your affairs no that's enough to
kill Jim Morrison a couple of times
that's amazing he's still goin yeah so
he basically retired from comedy and
performing and hung it all up and
outlived expectations I think due to the
fact that he's buying stem cells off the
black market in Mexico mmm-hmm and he
basically said you know like a year ago
the two years ago that he wanted to see
if he still had it he was getting tired
of waiting around to die can i still can
i still perform do i still have this and
he made a return of stage and did three
shows and I thought that's such a great
impetus to to follow and what a great
trajectory cuz you can find all the
story of his of his um I was career but
the heart can't wait to [ __ ] see this
thing well the heart and soul of it
really is about Joel Osborne see when
Jonathan Jonathan's to face the doc the
heart of the documentary is when he was
touring worldwide he was like kind of
like a Russell Peters back in the day he
was gone everywhere and he met this this
kid he's 12 years old he'd always be
backstage and asking for autographs and
sneaking in the shows he just saw this
like desire or you know fascination with
magic and comedy in this kid
Joel Osbourne and so he he basically
took him under his wing and every year
he came back to Australia Joel would get
a little older and he'd give a little
more responsibility and eventually he
was he was like like his road manager in
Australia and publicising all the events
and putting posters up everywhere MA and
getting a cut of this and selling the
magic hit in Australia and eventually
when Joel turned 18 he said you want to
be my road manager in the States and
Joel said yeah
and eventually joel joel is a guy that's
doing meditation he doesn't drink he
doesn't do drugs and this kid it comes
out to Vegas and is negotiating million
dollar deals with these casinos and
Jonathan's is drug addict and throwing
this 18 year old kid in the middle this
crazy [ __ ] scenarios and joy Joel's
like you know this is a beyond a doc
this is a good movie he goes you go to
the Golden Nugget and you tell those
[ __ ] Jonathan wants 2.5 you
told me shove it up your [ __ ] ass and
walk out to its limit or Jill's like I
guess so and so Joel goes in and and
Joel's very diplomatic and he got
everyone Jonathan wanted in a very
serene kind of way and so two people on
paper should never be in each other's
lives developed this great fraternal
relationship and Joel basically became
his like caretakers song through a
suicide attempt he saw him through drug
addiction and he basically got Jonathan
in a great place in his life and
eventually said okay I'm gonna go off
and become a comedian on my own and Joel
went to Australia and became a comic and
this is about these two reuniting for
one last tour and being on stage
together this is on all things comedy
this sounds like it's gonna win an award
well I you know we've gone through the
gauntlet with this thing and all things
comedy and soapbox have been nothing but
kind to us and help sir
to make a film like this it takes a lot
of money and I did it all out of my own
pocket quite a bit money quite a lot of
money in a hole on this thing but
soapbox said you know I talked to the
guys at all things economy they said hey
maybe we can help you get the finishing
funds for this and and finish the film
and so they sweeten it for us with color
and sound got it together and when we
were looking for a distribution partner
we thought let's go to all things comedy
right now perfectly so it's just I think
it's a perfect platform for it given the
content a nice company Steve you're a
great cop over there she had an idea
she's shooting something right now
shooting a pilot really yeah over there
was actually what she was doing that
because we had a little dust-up last
night yes we do you know what's funny
news right now she came walking in and
she was wearing this purple sweater and
she looked beautiful I was just saying
yeah that's that's how I ended up with
her I could just never break even in my
fantasy of breaking up with her I would
when she walked away I would get sad and
I would still get I'll get back in here
you know what I was right though last
night I wasn't right but you know Monday
when you're right there here come the
tears yeah yeah yeah probably not a good
thing to say you know in those moments
like can you get your emotions in check
you know it's probably not good to go
[ __ ] bud grant head coach oh and I'm
at that point but I'm learning thanks
yeah I'm learning things
so anyway sorry we got off track there
um how long you've been working on this
thing cuz these things like it takes a
link to take forever well the thing for
me is I was doing two at the same time I
basically did this just to do it just
I'd never done a doc I love Docs but I
knew enough about story narrative that I
was like I think I could tell the story
and I know these guys so well and I know
exactly the story I want to tell so when
I did the interviews it was six to eight
hours with Jonathan and six to eight
hours with Joel but I knew exactly what
to ask them you know getting the content
was different getting all the archival
footage and converting the archival
footage that's a whole nother process so
you was expensive and you were doing
this while you were writing that movie I
did a partner for you last year yes and
I have things coming out like dude who's
working harder than
you well know why your I haven't seen
you in the club's in a minute even
buried in a writers room in the editing
huh yeah I basically wrote the feature
on the road while I was kind of I'd come
back Monday Tuesday Wednesday edit the
documentary go on the road Thursday
Friday Saturday and write this feature
film just as an exercise to see if I
could do it well and then do shows at
night and do shows at night because I
basically thought I had Sullivan & Son
on the air I was the second Asian
American ever to have a sitcom and
nobody gave a flying [ __ ] it was the
first Margaret Margaret Cho was it and
it wasn't another one yeah after that
after that I was the second one then
came like fresh dog Ben came dr. Kenan
fresh off the boat I know what that is
because hers didn't work and they were
like you see yeah to hell with these ten
million billion people exactly yeah
that is what happened with redheads
being leads in movies that guy from
[ __ ] NYPD Blue after one season
walked and he did Jade and one other
movie and they didn't do well and they
were just like see this is why the
redhead male will never be a lead in a
[ __ ] moon ruined everything for you
he put us on the bench yeah he put us he
put his back into Richie Cunningham
world from billions is bringing you back
who's that guy
the dude from billions she's red hair
he's a ginger row like a UK actor he was
in the band of brothers who's one of the
leads and band of brothers I'm not
talking ensemble cast I'm saying the
[ __ ] film is on your freckled
shoulders hey there's a certain you
don't you know I call I call it
Hollywood head every once in a while I
see that guy he has a Hollywood head
yeah it's the [ __ ] brown of jet-black
hair with the cowlick the Superman
haircut look with the square [ __ ] jaw
if you had blue eyes in that that
[ __ ] guy is a loser I don't care if
he can act
he's a [ __ ] he will be listen I just
want to run my food truck I can't tell
you dude it was so big facial features
to those people look weird in real life
yeah you know what I mean they got was a
giant [ __ ] headache out they look
[ __ ] what they look like they were
drawn they look good on anime and spray
yeah yeah I got a big enough head I just
didn't have the right pin with you I can
tell you like Beckham it was [ __ ]
hilarious my first first time I came out
here this is way back when they had
black and white head shots which I
remember you're one with the staples and
it was black and white so don't even act
like you're [ __ ] not as you said it's
I went by William at first yeah then
bill then Billy then back to Bill I
finally said to Dave like out because I
was trying to find cuz every was saying
that he got a weird last name he I think
I got sucked into that showbiz thing and
then fine I was just like my name's bill
[ __ ] it so but I don't mind if you call
me bill Billy Oh William as long as
you're [ __ ] calling me I don't give
you [ __ ] as long as I'm working I'm fine
so I ended up like I would have liked
the black the black and white headshots
so with the moose in the hair in the mid
to late 90s yeah it looked like I had
hair color like somewhere between yours
and mine right so it looks like brown
hair so initially on low-budget [ __ ]
they they would try me out they would
just look at my credits and not look at
my tape or whatever and they would they
would say okay we'll give this guy shot
at the lead and dude okay you know
prepared three scenes and I would walk
in in the second they saw me like we're
just gonna through the first scene and I
knew what it was it was just like I
[ __ ] knew it I knew it it says it was
this [ __ ] like unwritten rule out
here but I always found it funny because
I've always looked at [ __ ] like that
going like I know where I'm going I
think this is just you know like when
you back in the day Lucien I have enough
white good and then I was just like I
know what he's saying I know what he's
saying I would just I would remember
your first headshot and I used to see
that stand-up no you never saw my first
headshot well not your first official
one but you were tilted sideways you
were smiling and you had this great
smile on your face and I always I always
thought cuz I cuz I knew you offstage I
was like I better paint him to like
smile to do that headshot because I
can't picture you like because now your
picture you see me like that Steve
they're like you wear your more kind of
like well this is what you saw in that
headshot was the smiling me was who I
thought I was right
I didn't realize see I have this theory
that your 20s is all about like I would
say this in the podcast your 20s you
just basically taking your childhood out
on people yeah
it was a good one or a bad one you and
you don't even know what you're doing
okay
so if you were raised right you're doing
something good okay but if you're you
know a little off or whatever then
you're hurting people and somewhere in
your 30s you stop blaming people and you
start working on yourself whatever and
then then you're 50 almost 51 you're
still in [ __ ] therapy so what that
was was that was prop that's who I was
believe it or not that smiling kid who's
who the [ __ ] I was when I felt safe all
right but when you saw me around there
this whole [ __ ] guarded thing that
you see that's all that is that's just
like stories cuz I get asked this when I
go you know every now and then like
people know I'm pals of you or start in
New York with you and you go do these
round pals I love it couple of fellas do
the radio shows and they're like what's
what's burr like what's bro and I always
say I we used to go to Yankee games
together
we'd go to sporting events together I
went to a million Yankee games I just
sat there rooting against them yoo-hoo
Wow Wow appreciating what especially the
98 Yankees the best [ __ ] team I ever
saw this is 2001 uh-huh no this is 2000
still get [ __ ] for that and I never did
it and today that time they gave me so
much [ __ ] for doing that bus gig that I
neveri I told him I didn't do it but I
never gave you a name I never know you
were tell me you like on I will never
you said don't say that cuz you'll get
shredded for the rest of your life if
you - they did a headlining set it was
old-school 45 minutes yeah upstairs at
the cellar Patrice Kevin Voss Norton
Keith all the killers were there yeah
they did on a [ __ ] hour on what my
bus gig was gonna be like trashing me
and through it it was so [ __ ] they
crushed me so hard
strangers were listening and laughing or
worse there was a couple women going oh
because they were looking at me I had
nothing I got [ __ ] so you gave me this
gig the gig was basically you go on a
bus and like from Midtown to Yankee
Stadium you had to do stand-up comedy
these guys from Atlanta had come up it
was the Braves it was the second time
the brace it was 99 all right nine no
you know what the fuss 2001 world
seriously 2001 is Arizona this also is
Arizona
Arizona and pitch okay so the Arizona
dynasty so these were fans from Arizona
yeah
and they had rented a party bus to go
from their hotel up to the [ __ ]
Yankee Stadium they wanted a comedian in
that [ __ ] traffic I can't imagine how
much time you had to do to do stand-up
and and in return you got a World Series
ticket and I was just like dude I'll
[ __ ] cuz a bomb I'll just sit there
all I gotta do is [ __ ] on the Yankees
for an hour I can do that for [ __ ] a
day I'll take the ticket I'll [ __ ]
leave but then you it and you couldn't
do it you said here's the opportunity do
it but don't tell him I quit they teased
me out of it you know what it wasn't it
wasn't even the trashing it was after
the pounding that I took and they all
laugh into it and I was just sitting
there like a punch-drunk fighter tree
sat down with next to me yeah in this
fatherly way he said bill I will stand
in front of that bus before I let you do
that gig if you want to go to a World
Series buy a ticket yeah I've got the
money and it was the first time I ever
thought like well I think I've earned
some sort of self-esteem as a comedian
yeah because you come up every it's just
one impossible situation after another
that you start to get institutionalized
that dude I haven't one time I went to
die to do this gig it was called a
birthday a private gig birthday party I
think Linda Rowe booked it or something
I don't know she booked this [ __ ] I
love her she booked me at this thing I
think it was her it was Roger Paul one
of those - yeah and I went there and
what it was was it wasn't a birthday
party there was an Irish guy getting
deported
because he got caught for [ __ ]
helping out the IRA and I just
remembered he went up first and I don't
know who he was talking about probably
Margaret Thatcher or one of the English
[ __ ] and he was like I got [ __ ] two
words for them and it's not happy
birthday and the whole place goes like
it goes nuts and they all marched up to
the bar and started drinking and only
the women were there not paying
attention I was standing there
unfortunate was two other comedians
bought all those [ __ ] prom shows that
stand up New York used to book in
Dangerfield stage of lives you have to a
half hour for the prom shows just for
people don't know you you would show up
in these [ __ ] kids in the parameter
they just want to have a good time on a
boat and it was on a little boat cruise
around the island of Manhattan and they
would have the dance music going they
would cut the music and then you had to
walk out into the middle of the dance
floor and start doing stand-up [ __ ]
comedy I did one crew one but was good
they actually put him in a room and I
had like a chance like dude I I can't
even remember the gigs they were that
traumatic they just sort of like flashes
and then you would bomb and then you're
on this boat you can't leave Patrice
would have stood in front of that boat
said oh dude I used to hide down by the
engine room and then you had to make
then you had to make the decision as the
boat was pulling in do I try to get
first in line and feel them staring at
the back of my head or do I hide here
like a rat and wait for him to get off
and one time I the first time I hid like
a rat and right as I thought they had
all left it was just one of them walked
off song as this black kid him ever just
looked at me I can't do that it's a face
he just looked at me kind of pursed his
lips and just slowly shook his head
as he was looking at me and he was
looking at me like man I don't know what
the [ __ ] you were thinking that you'd
ever be good at this [ __ ] that's why I
said yes to a buck because I was just
like I've already done gigs way worse
than this bus story and I'm getting a
World Series ticket out of this like
yeah I'm actually pissed at myself that
I didn't do the gig well I did it and
thank you for it cuz I got to see George
Bush through the opening pitch out it
was he nailed it after 9/11 it was like
a you four kind of vibe in the stadium
the rest of the world that we had and we
had empathy towards us
everyone kind of liked us then and yeah
felt we were victims but this pop fly
comes up and this guy in this kid go for
it and this guy catches the ball and
this kids kind of like still standing
there and the guys turn around waving
the ball and everybody in our section
starts pulling this guy boom give the
kid the ball give it to a kid give it to
a kid to a kid you start chanting I
start jack give it to the kid all
sections give it it's starting to spread
all the sections neighbor and give it to
the kid
and this guy's getting pounded people
are not letting up it's going on for two
minutes three minutes and eventually the
guy stands up and he turns around and he
makes a [ __ ] poor duck
he holds the ball out and so everybody
can see any hands into the kid right and
the kid stands up everybody claps you go
you're [ __ ] caved you should have kept
the ball laughing you go smoke this
everybody else is smoking it and then
everybody starts pounding this guy and
yelling about peer pressure so [ __ ]
funny everybody was dying laughing it
was the only time I saw a comic get like
laughs at a stadium from the crowd I've
always killed it Stadium Ani
oh I always killed the stadiums and
there was that there was a thing I had
this weird [ __ ] this weird I would
become a different person when I went to
a game for a while yeah but this is
before I was known cuz now they're like
oh that's that jerk-off from Comedy
Central's so now it's not fun but before
anybody knew who I was I would go into
his stadium dude I would be on the road
I used to embarrass Paul virzi I one
time I got I don't know I would just
become completely uninhibited and it was
just all about making my section laugh
and trying to have like a good set this
is before all those flat-screen tvs came
in and killed the class clown at the
sporting event cuz now everybody just
sits there staring at a cam yeah yeah so
I was at this this game it was the
Dolphins versus the bank Bengals and I
was yelling all of this [ __ ] you gotta
be bored you got to be own [ __ ] during
that game right I know I but I want to
go to all the stadiums so and which I
basically have I got six left in the
four major but then I found out some
rich guys already done it the [ __ ]
[ __ ] so I was trashing the Dolphins
because they were right in front of us
yeah and I was doing such a good job and
they were all laughing around me and
somebody said hey man gate because it
was a close game get on their kicker get
on their kicker so I just got this guy
carpenter and I just focused in on this
guy and this at this point they had the
flat-screen TVs but it was the Bengals
who are like barely in the NFL you know
they're stadium and [ __ ] so it's just
like they don't have like a lot of like
crazy [ __ ] going on so I started in on
this guy carpenter Birds he always
starts you're a liability and I had to
make sure that he didn't curse cuz it
was kids around there and I just started
in with this guy and I swear to god yeah
I was yelling [ __ ] about
getting it's not too late to get your
real estate license and I was talking
about his career after football and I
swear to god he picked up his T in the
net and he moved all the way down to the
other side and I am convinced I want to
believe is cuz the [ __ ] I was talking I
mean the guys the guys still a great
career then he went out but it was funny
because I never forgot his name then I
saw him in like Buffalo my God my god I
call virzi up there he is a carpenter I
did a couple times I felt like I got to
somebody one time I went to a game at
old Tiger Stadium or Briggs stadium as
my dad would call it and I sat it I
wanted to see it was the only state and
they had an upper deck all the way
around so I sat in the upper deck the
short porch out in right field and they
would there was an interleague game they
were playing the Pirates see now the
centerfield in left field to play catch
and the right fielder was playing catch
with like a backup catcher or something
so he was playing and the guy had just
the guy in right field had just hit an
inning-ending double play and I started
it on him about how they you know you do
[ __ ] like that that's how you get sent
down to the minors you're on the Pirates
you're barely into the league and you
know and it's a short porch time hanging
over this guy yelling and dude he threw
his next pitch his next throw and I
swear to god it sailed like eight feet
over the guy's [ __ ] head and then I
felt bad then I felt bad
you're the cooler now it's just like hey
dude I was just [ __ ] with you I'm
just trying to break I don't give a [ __ ]
about the Tigers I'm just being an
[ __ ] I had a buddy of mine he got
somebody at Fenway Park one time he was
yelling at the relief pitcher and he was
screaming yeah all of this [ __ ] this guy
and this guy is just stone-faced yeah
not acknowledging any of it and then
finally just quiet got quiet then my
buddy just goes I know you can hear me
right
and the guy broke into a big smile and
just started [ __ ] laughing you just
started [ __ ] laughing and then the
whole section left and like the guy yeah
that's you know that was it's actually
comedians IRA Proctor Boston go yeah
yeah
I know you can't hear me one of my
favorite stuff like that is I did this
college Oh years ago and screech was
just coming on the comedy scene
diamond right screech yeah Dustin
Diamond Dustin Diamond like diamond I
got this
you know this college campus and and so
we were double booked so they're like
you know what Steve why don't you open
and screech will Dustin Diamond will
close the show do what [ __ ] time is I
make sure I don't miss this [ __ ]
12:35 oh well fine I'll we started early
ok we're fine yeah yeah yeah so I go
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] that's fine
yeah no this is a good payday there's
colleges back in the day so they put us
in this big campus theater or whatever
it's like five thousand kids and I go up
and I'm like I'm like you know if Dustin
diamonds going after me I'm gonna bury
this [ __ ] so I just I I pull out all
the 4th of July fireworks yeah you know
dewpt:20 I like my best like hard hidden
cellar stuff and he goes try to bury a
childhood child stop that was just kind
of like pissed at the time like I was
still kind of like you know you were
taking your childhood out on him enough
you know with you know his residuals
he's not making [ __ ] you'd say you it's
ok so you try to bury that's the thing
what happened a when you're a little
younger and this guy's coming off the TV
credits and [ __ ] it ok so so yeah you're
probably right but anyways I go up to do
my thing and then screech goes up and I
you know you get that grace applause
five minutes it starts to dissipate and
eventually it's just silent and it's
like that that's seen in any Kaufman's
movie the Jim Carrey one we're doing at
college and slowly people are walking
out of the amphitheater and stuff I kind
of felt bad and I was gonna say then
how'd you feel Steve I felt really bad I
felt bad they all have those moments and
it's silent
it's quiet he just did a joke debuffs
and just absolutely pure silence just
you could hear a pin drop and then just
way in the back from a rafter in the
back it just here [ __ ] you screech and I
[ __ ] couldn't stop laughing I don't
think I've ever laughed harder cuz it
echoed you know it was just so quiet
anyway and I was [ __ ] in tears crying
so hard it was one of the worst like
hope it's worth at the right time it's
cry
it's [ __ ] soul-crushing and then you
see all that [ __ ] that he ended up doing
then he's got to grow the beard he's got
to try to seem edgy ER because he's did
you did porn that kid probably drove him
to porn that won't reach
I bet still echoes in his head Tuesday
and it made him do porn and this is the
thing that was actually respect he just
wanted to be the guy
I yelled [ __ ] you screech that's screech
that's what it becomes that's just
that's his Twitter handle hey speaking
of that did you uh as far as like
dealing with like people knowing who you
are did you see that documentary on Bill
Murray yet no this is documentary this
kid made about a sales bill about Bill
Murray yeah yeah like seeing it was all
these urban myths about you know hey we
were playing kickball and all of a
sudden Bill Murray showed up to played
three innings and then it was just
disappeared or he showed up at our house
party start French fried no one will
believe yes yeah yeah all of that [ __ ]
so he was investigating it and all this
type of stuff but like when you watch it
it's just this fascinating thing to see
it's a combination of him like living in
the moment and then also dealing with
how famous he is I feel yeah that it's
just like I'm gonna go on the offensive
here and be like so open and normal it's
gonna freak you out and then we're gonna
meet in the middle where I'm just a guy
named Bill it's [ __ ] yeah fascinating
mental judo he flipped it on you yeah
yeah and actually taught you something
and by the time you figure it out he's
gone and then you realize I didn't even
ask him for an autograph yeah yeah so he
actually gets like like I feel like this
is what he does so he can have a normal
existence you know what time I was
flying on a little [ __ ] puddle jumper
over to South Carolina and he's a part
owner yeah in a minor-league team there
and he was on my flight and dude he I
missed him by one seat
I was in the opposite row opposite of
the aisle the two seater and he sat on
the other side of the two seat on the
window yeah so I couldn't hear what he
was saying but he talked to that other
guy the whole [ __ ] life and I was
just like
I was almost there do you ever want to
be that guy I never I always hated that
I like I never liked like if I was
sitting next to Bill I don't know if I'd
say anything
III you know I might not I I never I
know about you know what it is what I
found with people at that level is if
you somehow know what their hobby is
they'll talk to you all [ __ ] day long
but if you go at them and talk to them
about what it is they they've done press
junkets around the [ __ ] world
yeah the same 20 questions and
variations of them and it's just like in
and you know a perfect reference
Groundhog Day and like yeah he made that
movie so yeah like I you know I also
have no I don't have a desire to get to
be that level of being known yeah where
you're just like his life is just
constantly this is such a weird thing to
say but being bombarded with compliments
that you can't get out of and then you
can't you know you don't understand q I
appreciate no you don't understand you
don't understand this is just this is
just in there would not letting go of
his hand and it's just like you get my
aunt Vicki you don't ya get a picture
can you can you leave them voice message
on my oh my stupid phone's not on and
then and then he walks another half a
foot oh my god I'm the biggest and it
just becomes that ya know is on video
yeah yeah now when you see it and you
see those whenever I see those people
there's a sadness because they're
walking around it's like they'd like
this [ __ ] they're like a monument
it's like you've become like a thing
you're not even like a [ __ ] person
anymore Zoo your zoo exhibition yeah
when I go out with Vince and like
especially when were in Chicago we walk
around I'm the guy people just hand a
camera - yeah just go take this and then
he handles it really well he's really
good at it he's he's good at he's great
but but then they say he likes people I
think there's like people I think you
have to like people but if you're like
your [ __ ] curmudgeon like me I don't
think yeah I like I'm acting like this
is an option to get that [ __ ] big but
I just when I look at it like that's
something when you get into the business
you think oh I want to win an Oscar
and I'm gonna direct the [ __ ] movie
and I'm gonna [ __ ] it and I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do that and then you've
when you get in it first of all you see
how [ __ ] hard it is and then secondly
is you when you actually start to see
what that thing is you can I looked at I
was just like oh it's creepy
yeah you can't eat you can't well that
now now with those [ __ ] like
everybody's it's like jagger Hoover
everybody's got like a [ __ ] camera
now like I was saying with you do the
fact that they came at you and could you
stay [ __ ] you Jackie Chan you [ __ ]
agent blah blah blah blah and then your
chair you there's no evidence of it and
then they just walked out and everything
happened nothing happened but like these
days they'd be fired from the night
shift at Best Buy you know it's like
that's yeah like Oh
shots fired there I saw what you just
did there I saw what you did there yeah
that that would be like the thing but
well Jesus you know what Steve I don't
know this has been [ __ ] great just to
go back it's funny how we go down memory
lane and there was like no they were
just all brutal stories that's what I
awful that's what I always the worst
story that ever happened to me it's the
meanest thing you've ever seen Bobby
Bobby
that's the worst I think if we if we
close it out you know we we tell people
that years ago the Patrice O'Neal roast
it was a pretreat O'Neal roast which was
the purest and greatest [ __ ] roast I
ever saw unfortunately got to be a part
of it because it wasn't for anybody else
it was for us I know now I think those
tapes of it you know everything ends up
online now but like it was is it the old
boston comedy club yeah and the amount
of people that showed up cuz they
finally wanted to see somebody shut
patrisa yeah because he had trashed all
the industry there everybody yes and
they wanted to see what happened so
Bobby when you can tell this was I I got
I was very I was me he's gonna get mad
on some level that were telling this
story though I was managed by Bearcats
at the time I don't [ __ ] Bobby last time
I I love Bobby by the way there's no way
not Bobby but you always get to a [ __ ]
Bobby and then II just out of these you
know arms you
the last time I saw my New York City
it's like a big st. Bernard there's
something about him he goes take your
ball cap off I go okay he goes he still
got hair and he walked away he was upset
that at my age are still he wanted me to
be bald and then he'd be happy like
that's that's who Bobby is you know I
know but you have to understand the
sadness behind that very cat's man who
just made he's like hey I got you is
this before after he became a dead cuz
he's a different guy now before yeah I
know now he's now he's like Bobby Bobby
Santa Claus Bobby Bobby we always want
we always Bobby knew he could be yeah
because I will say this about Bob
he has been 11 different people since
I've met him and each in each version
has been a better Bobby yeah he never
went in a worse direction yeah
definitely maybe stylistically with
clothes for a while Ramona moved out to
LA and he was starting to looking a
little cholo yeah I don't know yeah I
don't know what happened he he came out
here and he lost use performed akin
señores for a good year I think Keith
said that he said Bob move on to LA as a
Puerto Rican he came back a fat Mexican
we got bill we gotta get him out of LA
it's killing them cats gets me this like
audition at SNL but but not like the
audition where you go you got to put
yourself on tape so it's three
characters three impersonations this is
like again probably like late 90s early
2000s cellphones are not out nobody has
that tech remember that was a cattle
call to try the next to find the next
young hot talent to be on SNL and you
had to put yourself on tape so you
borrowed Bobby Kelley's camera video
camera he's very tech savvy and I
borrowed his camera and I put it I put a
DB tape in there and let it run for an
hour I just sat in front of the camera
and just let it run instead of stopping
and starting
I was like I'll just edit out I'll just
edit them and get the best parts and
that'll be my tape so I give Bobby the
the camera back and I give them I leave
the tape and I go feel free
you forgot the tape wasn't no you look I
left the tape in there I go just tape
over it because those are kind of
expensive at the time
Jesus Christ Steve did you know what you
were dealing with I thought you thought
you forgot it was in there no I'm a
trusting person so I him it was like a
three pack so I gave him two extra tapes
I said Bobby Kelly invented the dark web
yeah he's like he's like a cataclysmic
moment in the dark web and you've left
that to you how I always thought I
thought you forgot it was in there
no no I I left it in there I go just I'm
having less sympathy you know who he was
tape over it so he what he does is at
the Patrice Roast
he doesn't even prepare much no no no
you gotta wait you telling us to fast he
[ __ ] uploaded it Toby okay good yeah
onto this computer and then kept it oh
yeah kept all of it for like a year
waiting for the perfect time to unveil
it yeah and then he edited together the
worst the absolute wars pardon me
talking to myself the most embarrassing
things you singing dr. danke Schoen as
doing Wayne fresh blood like commercial
at the time dude let me tell you some
even the best version of that was
probably horrific yeah the worst version
of it was absolutely abysmal and
probably an insured why never worked in
New York City probably after that but he
took it edited together this awful
presentation of my as audition and
instead of doing material he wheeled out
a TV with the videotape and put the VCR
tape in and you were there this is why
did he went up and he tried a few jokes
oh that only did okay and he was like
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] and then he
started telling a story of how you left
this tape in and you have to see it it's
so bad and it made no sense because you
weren't there I wasn't seeing at the
Comedy Cellar so yeah we weren't
roasting you and then he put it into it
it was so [ __ ] bad that the meanest
people in standup I remember sitting
next to the late great greg Giraldo we
were going shut it off
turn it off Bobby shut it off and that
was the end of his set yeah and I
remember dude I came over to the cellar
people and I saw you look at me
I saw you dude shoulders slumped and I
came over I said I go hey man
III think I apologize said sorry about
that and you said I'll never forget you
looked you've barely looked at me like
surprised you're even talking to me and
I tried to tell Bobby afterwards now
this is Bobby five versions ago the new
Bobby new Bobby wouldn't do this Bobby's
like a [ __ ] iPhone daddy Bobby
wouldn't do this yeah not not daddy
Bobby yeah but this is this is this is
post chill Oh Bobby he's like an iphone
every version gets better I'm telling
you he's a better person than I am right
now and I'm not just saying that like
he's a [ __ ] amazing dude now but back
then dark went dark web Bob I tried to
explain to him going Bobby a [ __ ]
crazy and you have to explain he was
going it was like he was but I think
going back that maybe it was starting to
enter that he did some [ __ ] up but the
thing about Bob is though if you just
talked to him and you hear how he was
brought up and it's just like oh now I
get it cuz he was the Bobby Kelly was
the first guy I ever met whose line was
further down the street than mine cuz
you know that thing you know all the
black comics try to teach the white
comics how to sit around and you know
bust balls as we called it like I
remember me and Bob where we lived in
that game never got a laugh he was like
goddamn Jesus bill [ __ ] yeah they would
just make fun of your shirt and we lived
in yeah at least my mom isn't dead yeah
like and it's just there wasn't a joke
it was just it was [ __ ] mean and he
was the only guy I met someday I mean
bob has to do a [ __ ] I might to I'm
back to this this summer if I got a
chance to go up and do his podcast oh it
Bobby yeah the shed if we talked about
when we were actually roommates two of
the most damaged [ __ ] lunatics yeah
but we still had a ton of fun do you
know what he did one time this is so
[ __ ] funny and I was so [ __ ] mad
at him now but I just think of how like
why did I care this is so funny he had
first of all he was like you know he was
a
street kid so if anybody left anything
on the [ __ ] sidewalk he would bring
it in like couches I was like pop
there's probably bedbugs and yakking
like [ __ ] HIV on that they get this
thing to [ __ ] a [ __ ]
steam-cleaning so somebody had left like
the prototype for a Stairmaster on the
sidewalk dude and when I tell you this
thing was bare like you ever see like
you know you look at it like a really
old car yeah we're like you opened the
hood and you look down and you can see
your driveway you know what I mean
there's like there's just bare minimal
parts
this was the Stairmaster version of this
yeah so we were in this thing where we
were trying we would like having this
war yeah
which is so dumb to do this with Bob
because Bob's gonna win and it was just
basically he [ __ ] at my computer I
[ __ ] with his computer he [ __ ] with
my food I'm [ __ ] with his food and
whatever I did I've gotten him last yeah
these [ __ ] practical jokes and we're
doing this in a railroad apartment where
I had a walkthrough bedroom and he slept
in the living room that's where we lived
it was like [ __ ] you ever see those
those things will they stick a tiger and
a lion and a pit to see what happens
yeah they just kill each other that's
what the [ __ ] happened so he's on this
[ __ ] Stairmaster and I had an
audition for Conan O'Brien which I know
bugged him yeah I know bugged him cuz no
one was appreciating how funny he was
because he was considered crass or
whatever the [ __ ] it was right so he was
on this [ __ ] Stairmaster dude okay
and it's a railroad apartment so where
he is in the living room okay okay then
to the right there was a little hallway
that led into the kitchen yeah and in
that little hallway was a door also to
the right that led into the bathroom so
I was on the same side the same wall
that he was on in the bathroom got it
yeah and he was on that [ __ ]
Stairmaster and I got myself all dressed
up I got the mousse in my hair that I
used to have and I'm all ready to go do
my [ __ ] audition at the comic store
for Conan O'Brien yeah and he had spent
sitting there with you remember those
racquetballs those blue racquetballs he
had one of those in his [ __ ] hand and
he was on this thing dude and when I
tell you like Roger Clemens I'm coming
out of the bathroom he can't even see me
like a pool shot throws like a [ __ ]
mile-an-hour heater yeah it I meant all
I heard was it hit the [ __ ] wall and
dude came right in and hit me right in
the mouth really on my lip [ __ ] split
and I was bleeding and he was all I
remember he was on he was on the
Stairmaster laughing and then he felt
that do my lips swelled up an audition
and I got like a piece of steel yeah did
you get it yeah I think I might have I
don't think I did I don't think I did I
think it was suggesting to them to know
who I was dude I literally I mean I tuck
my shirt in like this is how much I gave
a [ __ ] about this thing and Bobby like
it's one of the greatest things anybody
ever did to me as far as like a
practical joke dude if you just did the
degree of difficulty if he was standing
flat-footed could never do that this guy
was on a [ __ ] with skinny Bobby he
was unlike any he was yeah dude this was
matinee idol Bobby there was one time he
told me he got the this is a video
cameras you could communicate like set
it up I love this it always ends up
talking about what [ __ ] no Bobby Johnny
yeah
we're not [ __ ] no no come on no no of
course but but he got this little video
camera that does what FaceTime does
right its face time before face time
he's like dude you got hate when these
cameras are great so he shows it to me
he's talking to Dane Cook on the thing
and I still have a minidisc player in
one of these boxes cuz he told me that
that was the lady thing he tells me to
buy this thing I buy he's the only one I
know that has it I call him up I go hey
what's up he hung up on me I never used
it again the great thing about being
friends up there in Bucks
yeah but the great thing about being
friends with him is like the the you
just if you just drafted behind him like
if you were in a bike race yeah the
amount of Technology [ __ ] that he would
just sell to you ah well you know he was
like he was the king of he would he
would get something a fold-up bike a
[ __ ] like some James Bond level
flashlight and then Horace months he
hates it and he gives it to you and it's
kind of cool that he hated it he was
just see over it he know he knows what
the next thing is yeah cuz he's
constantly buying the new [ __ ] this one
time I was I was rollerblading
I was playing roller hockey in Central
Park
broke my stick some rollerblading at the
time in Hell's Kitchen because Bobby and
Norton lived in Hell's Kitchen and I'm
coming down like ninth Avenue or
whatever and I see Bobby and Norton walk
out of a Starbucks and they look at me
and they just start dying laughing cuz
they see me in rollerblades right and
they're [ __ ] howling they're not
somebody were gonna cross check them and
they didn't see so I come skating down
and hey I'm walking they're walking
towards me I'm skating towards them and
I'm going like I'm making my way through
the middle of them and they both had
their coffees in each other I just
smacked the coffee's out of both their
hands no skating and then I turned
around and they were both dying laughing
so it was like you know it's what they
do I love those guys
the only thing I miss about the East
Coast but you know something I go back
and it's it's not the same because wrong
went to the cellar a little bit ago and
the cellars the same but the vibe
upstairs is not the same somebody said
it's like going into like a one of those
coffee bean okay it's just like all of
the every reason that you were afraid to
go in there now is gone yeah and what
they don't understand is that we were
all scared like what I can't stand is
how soft people are running [ __ ] now
it's like it's not making it better to
make everything soft this is so [ __ ]
up dude I was just you know I had to go
to the doctor right I got I didn't
realize I get super dehydrated on this
this [ __ ] flight back from Israel
right like I was on a plane for like 24
hours and just watch five movies and
didn't drink anything [ __ ] next day I
felt like I had the clap or something it
was just like just like I didn't [ __ ]
anybody I know what the [ __ ] wrong
with me
yeah and I just been drinking like pure
cranberry juice for two weeks and I'm
finally better and but I had to go to
doctor just to make sure everything was
all right right so there was a diner
downstairs so I got out of the
old-school diner has like the [ __ ]
you know the you can just sit at the at
the little bar area
order some bacon and eggs and they had
the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue
yeah in like Tyra Banks is on the cover
right still looks [ __ ] great man
crushing it right now and I'm like
alright so that's that little thing that
you know now they can exist she's in her
40s and we're progressive we put on the
cover dude I open the thing up in the
first two
thing is to fat chicks and like string
bikinis and I'm like alright they had to
do that just to be like blah blah blah
and then I turn then there's a hottie
then there's like an older woman who
does Pilates who looks good for her age
but I mean you know yeah and then there
was another one that was like another
tune it's just like what the fun I just
laughed I'm like at the trans in the
rainbow but it's just like I get it I
it's just like one of those [ __ ]
things where I just think it's so
[ __ ] funny like like why can't you
just accept the fact that you're not a
ten the way I do like I I never looked
at Brad Pitt in Fight Club and be like
oh you know I just created
impossible images for me to live up to
now I have to have eight pack abs I
inspired me to go to the gym I know I'm
never gonna look like a but they don't
have to put like like on the cover of
men's health they don't have to have
some guy with like a beer belly wearing
a half a shirt so I can feel better
about myself and feels safe enough to
open the [ __ ] magazine dude these
people that are incredible shape and
that are beautiful and everything should
it [ __ ] inspire you or whatever to do
something with your [ __ ] life yeah
because they never talk about the other
side of being that good-looking where
it's just like those people's careers
are over in their [ __ ] 30s yeah
I think that's why Tyra Banks was so
smart that she did the whole thing where
it's now now I'm gonna pick the next
good-looking whatever you know but model
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they do
over there like when everybody's trying
to appease everybody like when
McDonald's after that dock came out and
it's like oh we got to be healthy it's
like no you gotta be McDonald's it's why
I like Carl's jr. cause you're like do
you eat like [ __ ] then [ __ ] come on
down right because we we don't give a
[ __ ] we'll put a taco hell I've seen
comedians do that Camino there's no
jokes here and then they try to be the
serious copy not the [ __ ] serious
comic no let's do do this will be a
whole nother hour for you this let's
just let's say the name of the
documentary is always amazed it's
amazing it's available on the all things
comedy YouTube channel for free
June 3rd Monday June 3rd would Monday
June 3rd it's free it's on YouTube check
it out spread the word and then you and
I you were gracious enough to come down
and do a great role for us in the
opening act
I'm about my early years in stand-up and
that's gonna come out later on this year
so everything dude I'm proud of you man
because you're making your own
opportunity out here and so many people
just sit on the couch and [ __ ] and
you're [ __ ] working your app can tell
by that inhale and exhale you just did
how [ __ ] tired you are yeah no I
totally respect what you're doing and
you're making your own way and then when
you do that dude
you become you know is invincible as you
could be out here you got a bet on
yourself dude so have to yeah yeah I'm
proud of you Steve burn everybody thank
you so much for coming down you got a
bill thanks for having me all right is
he advertising helix helix helix sleep
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match the body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper like a plush or firm bred bed
sorry with HELOCs helix there's no more
guessing or compromising so just go to
helix sleep calm slash bar take their
two minutes sleep quiz gross and they'll
match you to a mattress that will keep
you give you the best sleep of your life
four couples helix can even split the
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side HELOCs sleep
was even awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 20,000 19 by GQ
and Wyatt magazine and CNN called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on they also endorsed Hillary
Clinton sorry did I mention I'm in a
public bathroom reading this that's why
it's echoing no I'm not taking a [ __ ]
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for hundreds for a hundred
nights risk-free gross right now hellix
is offering up to $125 off mattress
orders for our listeners gapped $125 off
helix sleep calm / / that's helic sleep
calm / / / $125 off your order
helix sleep calm / BER
long story why I'm in this [ __ ]
bathroom they're doing rehearsals in the
other room this is the only [ __ ]
quiet place all right so don't give me
[ __ ]
[ __ ] box butcher box makes it easy
to get high-quality meat that you can
trust every month butcher bucks delivers
1% grass fed and grass finished beef
free or range organic chicken heritage
breed pork my favorite and wild alaskan
salmon the salmon is wild directly to
you Dilla
the incredible quality of butcher box
meat starts with the commitment to
humanely raised animals that are never
fed antibiotics or hormones before
they're slaughtered did we mention it's
delivered right to your door choose from
four curated boxes including a mix of
high quality grass-fed grass-finished
beef free-range organic chicken and
heritage breed pork or customized room
box that you can get exactly what you
and your family love butcher box also
has wild caught Alaskan sockeye salmon
and butcher box bacon that is sourced
from heritage breed pigs and is uncured
nitrate free and sugar free there's no
way no easier way to get high quality
meat you can trust there's no commitment
you can cancel anytime Jesus Christ
they're going to say it again
grass-finished beef or 100% grass-fed
beef we got it means the cattle ain't
nothing but grass their entire life
for the ultimate barbecue bundle
absolutely free and your first butcher
bucks plus $20 off go to butcher box com
/ / in a promo code / that's to New York
strip steaks baby back ribs and 2 pounds
of ground beef my mouth is literally
watering reading this free in your first
box plus $20 off butcher box crown / / I
rented the promo code bur
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
May 30th 2011 happy Memorial Day
happy Memorial Day
you should be out at a parade for the
truths but you're just sleeping off a
hangover cuz you are a [ __ ] selfish
[ __ ] you wave hello to the troops at the
airport but when they give him a day and
you're supposed to be out there you're
laying in your [ __ ] bed you douche a
what's going on I'm in my bed - I notice
you have braces I have braces - what's
that line from hi everybody the beef
with some pothead movie oh boy oh boy
who took Tylenol PM last night I did i
roofied myself everybody you ever just
really really really [ __ ] tired
[ __ ] tired Joe don't I slept like a
[ __ ] stone kid I was really tired
last night I was nodding off I was on my
couch and what the [ __ ] was I doing I
was dealing with my dog who's afraid of
the wind
he's like the wind am I gonna sing this
whole [ __ ] podcast my dog does not
like wind it freaks the [ __ ] thing
out and it eats its way out of its cage
I call it the cage the dog trainer calls
it the Casa which is Spanish for the
cage no it is it oh I took two years of
espanol Cebu play and Casa means house
so what are you suggesting is it's not a
cage cage implies that it's something
negative and you tell what I have a shut
up you useless [ __ ]
alright go trim your [ __ ] baby
and stay out of my head all right it's a
[ __ ] cage the dog is in a kill breaks
out of a house you know don't you break
into a house oh my god it's so awesome I
have to get in there and see what kind
of stuff they have you break into a
house but when you break out of a
structure that's not a home okay when
you don't give a [ __ ] that your gums are
bleeding and you're scraping the chest
hair off of your torso so you can
squeeze through a [ __ ] porthole that
your fat-ass body can't fit through
that's not a house that's not a casa
that's not limb mace all or whatever the
[ __ ] it isn't French we can't think of
what we didn't mean with a CH what is
French for house chapeau was a [ __ ]
hatch la chemise was a shirt mo show me
angel no members uh I'll go [ __ ]
yourself I flunked you know something I
actually took French one past that then
was but was too dumb to go on to French
too so they actually had French to a the
triple a of [ __ ] French part did and I
flunked so bad I flunked that class so
badly my dad made me go back to French
one to get the basics and I then went
back and flunk that Jesus Christ still a
little sicker people if you wonder why
I'm a comedian that little that little
story I just gave you right there that
I'll let you know right there then I'll
let you know you know the fact that I
could go back in time and do worse than
I did the first time you know do you
guys have a seat back to the future when
Marty McFly goes back you know and he
just starts writing all the wrongs and
when he comes back to the future he's
got a Toyota 4runner right and
everything worked out he got the girl of
his dreams I did that real life I went
back in time I went back to French one
and I actually ended up doing worse so
because of that I never liked that
trilogy everyone else was just going
along for the ride and I was sitting
there going through that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
alright he'd go back in time and and he
would do even [ __ ] worse all right
let's move on here this is the Monday
morning podcast everybody um for those
of you who enjoy the sound of my voice
and feel like you can't get enough of it
just in case you missed it last week I
actually was on the Adam Carolla podcast
the most downloaded podcast in the
history of podcasting they even had the
t-shirts some sort of Guinness Book of
World Records that they set for a number
of downloads I was on last week's
episode and I had a great [ __ ] time
which one was recorded live at Jon
Lovitz his comedy club at Universal
[ __ ] strip-mall whatever the [ __ ] you
call that thing this big thing out here
called Universal I think they used to
make movies and at some point they just
made a left turn and they were like
let's just stick like 12 shitty
restaurants next to each other and a big
IMAX theater and then we'll have some
stupid rides and I got a feeling they
had a bunch of fat [ __ ] and Hawaiian
shirts will show up what do you guys
think and the other way yeah let's
[ __ ] do it you know what they were
right they were right a bunch of fatties
walking around with their swollen feet
you ever look you ever look down a fat
people's feet you have a look at that
[ __ ] you know they're already fat
because they had a whole bag of [ __ ]
M&Ms on the way over there one of those
giant [ __ ] bags you know the kind of
bag it's so [ __ ] big that if you were
making a brick wall if one of the bricks
was just the bag of M&Ms you it we would
still wouldn't it wouldn't compromise
the structure you could just concrete
right over the [ __ ] thing what's with
the yellow brick that's a big bag of M&M
sweetheart my fat [ __ ] uncle showed
up with that and he dropped it on the
ground and he couldn't pick it up and we
just sat there laughing at him
my name is that come on
come on help me pick it up and we just
sat there laughing at him you pick it up
you fat [ __ ] come on earn it well see
the problem was there was a there was a
bit of a yeah probably a 15% grade in my
front yard so the fat [ __ ] bends down
and he rolled he fell backwards on his
big toddler ass and I whacked his head
off the curb and I went to jail for
eight months on a manslaughter charge
and I also have to part of my community
service is I have to talk about the
dangers of bullying but in a tribute to
him we took that big bag of M&Ms and we
we put it right in the wall there God
rest his soul um what the [ __ ] am I
talking about
on the Monday morning podcast has a
donation button everybody do you have a
dollar you got 20 bucks just burning a
hole in your pocket what are you gonna
do it what you gonna do with that money
huh you're gonna spend it on that
[ __ ] unappreciative [ __ ] sitting
across from me right now who can't hear
what you listening to huh you can
listening to it on your iPod she's
sitting right across Andrew look at her
look at that stupid [ __ ] side of her
face yeah you married that you're
legally bound to that what are you gonna
do spend another 20 bucks on her getting
her some sort of [ __ ] I don't know
appetizer at Applebee's is that what you
gonna do is that what you laughing right
now aren't you this is worth the twenty
she isn't she's not gonna give a [ __ ]
what's she doing right now looking
around the room you know looking for for
a [ __ ] a different dick with it with
the bigger dollar sign on it uh you know
you wouldn't know that this was a
holiday with the amount of meanness that
I'm spewing here I'm a little frustrated
I'm still trying to get over this
[ __ ] cold that I've had all goddamn
week and I'm also frustrated because
I've been going onstage
going off in support of Lance Armstrong
and I'm really beginning to realize how
few people give a [ __ ] about bicycle
racing you know I actually got to be
honest with you I actually put that out
there and somebody connected with the
tour sent me an email
and said he thought that the [ __ ] I said
last week was [ __ ] hilarious when I
was trashing that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that piece of [ __ ] Tyler Hamilton Tyler
Hamilton you what you guys understand
first of all those of you are actually
keeping up on the Lance Armstrong story
all four of you do you understand that
he's not gonna get caught the guy took
[ __ ] 500 goddamn tests he passed them
all so now all they can do is just get
people to say that they saw him do it
that's not gonna hold up in court and
not to mention the people coming forward
are [ __ ] known cheats you know Tyler
Hamilton this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is his background the balls of this
guy American cyclist Tyler Hamilton
announced his retirement Friday this is
an article October 8 I'm sorry April 18
2009 oh I did research this week okay he
announced his retirement Friday why
because he accomplished everything he
could accomplish in that wonderful sport
no he retired Friday after testing
positive for the steroid DHEA which he
said he knowingly ingested in an
over-the-counter herbal and anti
depressant all right here's a guy he's
on antidepressants
Annie's taking steroids this is the guy
that's gonna bring you down an own
[ __ ] cheat
he was just it was the second doping
offense for the veteran rider who tested
positive for now I don't offend gay
people here he tested positive for homo
logu as' allowed blood transfusion he
got a big bag of semen evidently shot
into his [ __ ] veins to add to the
testosterone Jesus Christ how the [ __ ]
did he win that year Homa globe glow
glow bliss blood transfusion 2004 and
served a mandatory two-year suspension
even as he disputed the test results
through two rounds of arbitration these
are the kinds of people who are coming
up all right this guy's life's over
he wrote a bicycle until he was 30
you know do you realize how big a hole
that isn't your resume when you try to
get back into the real world and try and
get a desk job gee you know it's weird
do you have any sort of job experience
um I wrote a bicycle from age 8 to 30
yeah and then I got fired I got fired
from riding a bicycle and now I would
like a management position hey Tyler why
don't you go [ __ ] yourself
so then what does he do oh Jesus what do
i do do I write a book I don't want to
write a book that's work what else
should I do what if I just go in 60
minutes and I read out Lance Armstrong
you piece of [ __ ]
douche bag of the [ __ ] month this
[ __ ] guy Tyler Hamilton you believe I
can't believe that [ __ ] okay first of
all people I'm gonna tell you this right
now you can't ride a bicycle I sent it
last week you can't ride a bicycle 30
miles a [ __ ] hour up a goddamn
Mountain all right for a month you can't
do that without being on drugs all right
so get your [ __ ] heads out of Santa
Clauses ass they're all on drugs okay
they're on drugs yes all of them so what
are you gonna do to take it away from
Lance and give it to the other drugged
up guys this is [ __ ] stupid this is
the 2004 Red Sox versus the 2004 Yankees
are roided-up guys beat your roided-up
guys he won seven in a row seven he won
seven in a row case closed on to the
next one I don't want to talk about it
anymore
voices in my head stop bringing it up
god damn it I gotta blow my nose hang on
a second I gotta hit pause alright I'm
back Jesus Christ I swear to God if this
[ __ ] cold lasts one more damn day I'm
shaving the mustache right out of my
beard I'm gonna look like [ __ ] Abe
Lincoln nothing worse than blowing your
nose when you got a moustache it's like
a four-hour process alright so anyways
back to the damn Park
speaking of sports how about those
Boston Bruins huh all you [ __ ] haters
where's your team huh they're out their
little [ __ ] charity golf game raising
money for cancer that's what they're
doing there's only two teams left people
the Boston Bruins and the Vancouver
Canucks the only professional sports
team that throughout its history has
dressed worse than Sinbad the ugliest
[ __ ] uniforms ladies and gentlemen
known to [ __ ] man known to all of
sports for a good 20 [ __ ] years
horrific apps they came out of the gate
with one of the great uniforms of all
[ __ ] time and then what happened what
happened in the eighties they decided we
need to switch it up a little bit see
the problem is is not only are they in
Canada they are way on the west coast
way out they don't even know what the
[ __ ] going on they don't know what
styles are in so in the [ __ ] early
80s they switch their goddamn uniform
something like that you know it was was
disco finally made it to Vancouver by
1982 and when everybody else was
listening to the Talking Heads right the
last couple of police albums they were
still up there do a little dance make a
rear of and then they came up with the
ugliest [ __ ] goddamn uniform I've
ever seen in my life and the away
jerseys were bad enough but the home
ones I'm telling you were the ugly
there's a picture of Cam Neely
I'm gonna have it up on the EMM
podcast.com the official fan page of the
Monday morning podcast of him in that
uniform and I swear to God when you see
him in that uniform you would actually
consider dropping the gloves with the
guy that's how bad these
[ __ ] uniforms are so these douchebags
and their little [ __ ] mining town way
on the west coast of Canada way out
there you know they live on the other
side of the [ __ ] Rockies okay way the
[ __ ] out there all right like if you
were in Seattle and decided that you
were gonna drive to Alaska that only be
one little [ __ ] ass [ __ ] town on the
way there and that town is called
Vancouver you know what's funny about
those [ __ ] they actually think that
they're cosmopolitan up there they got a
bit of an attitude people they think
that they have this [ __ ] you know let's
do some ecstasy we got a couple of
nightclubs up here alright so what are
these dumb [ __ ] do after they for
[ __ ] years
we're the ugliest [ __ ] hunk of [ __ ]
uniform I've ever seen in my life
imma being in sixth grade when I saw
that uniform go and that is [ __ ]
horrific you know I'm in sixth grade
people I just stop coloring I should
have loved that uniform that's what it
looks like looks like one a five year
old member when you did that when you
were five you grabbed every crayon in
the box and you just started writing
letters you know because you thought
that would make the [ __ ] girl look at
you you know cuz you knew you wanted to
do something too but you didn't quite
know what because there was no internet
so you didn't know what [ __ ] was yet
because you were allowed to have a
childhood you know that's what those
[ __ ] uniforms look like and you know
what's amazing is these [ __ ]
they finally admit that they made a
fashion error and they go back to the
original good idea that they had and
then what do they do they [ __ ] it up
they [ __ ] it up they went back to the
blue and white with a little bit of
green then they got to see on their
thing and then they got this [ __ ]
killer whale coming out of the top of
the sea looking like a [ __ ] whale
centaur terrific they just you know what
it is they just couldn't 100% admit that
they made a [ __ ] mistake and you just
went back to the original which is what
the [ __ ] they should have done just like
the Jets as dumb as those green [ __ ]
are they real
is that those uniforms they wore with
Richard Todd and freamon McNeil were a
[ __ ] mistake terrible mistake
Bill Parcells came in right with his big
[ __ ] bunt pushing out his Dockers and
he says listen we're going back to the
original and they were like whoa because
we want to win everybody out there's
gonna go out there dress like Joe Willie
you got a [ __ ] problem with that
Wesley Walker doesn't have a ring rest
my case actually I think he wore it
early on
I should have picked him whatever Marty
Lyons never got a ring even though he
looked like Merlin Olsen I [ __ ] hang on
a second Jesus all right I'm back where
was I oh that's right trashing the
Vancouver Canucks in that little mining
town way out there in the west coast and
British Columbia yeah so they couldn't
admit that they made a [ __ ] mistake
so now they got this whale coming out of
the letter C I [ __ ] hate it I went up
there I went to a game up there and I
wanted to get a [ __ ] Jersey I just
couldn't get myself to do you know I was
like all right I'm living on the west
coast now I need a West Coast team I
like the Canucks I like that they went
back to their uniform then I looked at
it closely and I saw that stupid whale
coming out of there looking like when
that [ __ ] alien thing comes out of
that dudes stomach in that movie I can't
remember you know that thing that comes
out of the [ __ ] alien you know
remember in the alien in that movie
alien right then i say alien enough
times in that sentence when it opens its
mouth and then for some reason rather
than using its big mouth its uses its
little mouth that nibble thing that's
what it had they have the whale version
of that coming out of the letter C they
just you know I don't [ __ ] know then
they got this the [ __ ] twins they're
you know who is brothers on the same
[ __ ] team it's until I have a rule
against that I know you can't have all a
bunch of brothers on the same battleship
because of though at that time in World
War two when the boat got sunk and then
some poor mom and dad they lost five
kids at the same [ __ ] time is
the same rule with sports why do you got
two blood relatives on the same goddamn
team why is it was it like a mom-and-pop
[ __ ] hardware store or something ah
how do you [ __ ] I'm just trying
to work up some hatred I really don't
have any hatred for Vancouver I really
don't even know [ __ ] about your city and
know why cuz you're never in the nose
except once every [ __ ] goddamn
millennium your host and Olympics you
know why why cuz you got snow it's not
cuz you got a good [ __ ] City
hey Cleo knock it off goddamn dog I have
a pitbull that's afraid of the wind
she's like the wind what is this song
about she's like the wind is that about
love lost do you know I was watching one
of these goddamn these channels that
shows you know it's Memorial Day weekend
so they're given all that talking heads
to the [ __ ] weekend off so they're
just showing a bunch of rock concerts
and I saw though here's here's my
underrated for underrated overrated for
the week underrated the who live concert
video at the Isle of Wight best Keith
moon footage you're ever gonna [ __ ]
see I've never been that into Keith Moon
I like the I love the who I love they're
recorded music but I've never seen good
footage it's oh he's always on TV like
pretending to drum you know or like
magic bus or something like that and he
has a weird way of holding the sticks so
just because of that they never seemed
like there was a lot of power and then
there was that one where he blew his
drum kit up and Pete Townsend hurt his
ear and I always find that was something
I always [ __ ] hated I hated how they
destroyed their instruments if I didn't
[ __ ] I you know just watching you know
watching Pete's smashing a guitar
whenever I watched I was like - just
giving him me give it to somebody in the
crowd why would you do that there's a
bunch of wannabe rock stars in the crowd
that would kill for that guitar haha
Peter you put that guitar down young man
matter people teased you about your big
[ __ ] nose you're a rock star now
knock it off then they'd be blows up
that drum kit it just it makes you sick
makes you [ __ ] sick me anyways so
anyway so I never saw any good footage
dude that guy I already knew he was a
beast that guy that guy [ __ ] without
a doubt without a doubt one of the most
original drummers of all time dare I say
the most original rock drummer ever I
love [ __ ] John Bonham and and he laid
down the blueprint but when I hear
Bonham play I mean he granted he put it
put he put it 20 years into the future
but still I kind of could see some sort
of like I look at Keith Moon I don't see
any link to what the [ __ ] yeah what did
he watch Tito Puente it's like he was
like a percussionist you should have
been standing up with some Tim Bali's
the way the guy was playing it's just
it's [ __ ] mind-blowing absolutely
mind-blowing he's spinning the sticks
and he's doing this thing where he slams
it on the snare and it goes flying up in
the air like that's what Tommy Lee got
that [ __ ] so that's my underrated for
the week somebody actually hasn't
overrated where the [ __ ] is it here let
me let me let me overrate it the state
of Florida's sports fans Miami Heat
bandwagon errs Florida Marlins Orlando
fans Jacksonville Jaguar to be moving at
the beginning of two years ago Florida
Panthers suck etc etc dude that is the
most lazy overrated you started off we
were actually making some points and
then you just throw out a bunch of
topics he's just putting it on my
shoulders I got to bring it home that's
what you did you just started a project
like some broad and then you're like can
you just
what I thought you said you were
cleaning the kitchen now you [ __ ]
move it that's what you just did to me
and that overrated there I got to go off
in there let me tell you something I
hate to tell you this every sports
franchise everybody's bandwagon all
right go look at footage of when your
team sucked you know you think I was
watching the Bruins after [ __ ] Ray
Bourque left and we sucked a big bag of
dicks for like three years to be honest
with you I had a lot to do with that
clutching grab [ __ ] awful [ __ ] just a
terrible period for hockey you know no
wonder Tampa won a [ __ ] goddamn I mean
that that's that's why they had the
strike they were like how [ __ ] bad is
our league that the Tampa Bay Lightning
just won a Stanley Cup did you see that
Stanley Cup parade there was like eight
people there you know they thought it
was a [ __ ] spittoon yeah so I would
say everybody you know that that you
know you got bandwagon fat Yankee fans
of bandwagon fans if you watch
highlights of them in the 80s or when
Roger Maris broke Babe Ruth's [ __ ]
homerun record I mean you could have
[ __ ] walked up to the gate bought a
stack of [ __ ] 20 tickets all next to
each other out in a goddamn outfield you
know [ __ ] there was nobody at Bruins
games nobody at Celtic games when we
suck then we get the big three and then
all of a sudden everybody's there
everybody's got bandwagon fans man I
also think Jacksonville is moving out
because it's Jacksonville you know where
they got one radio station out there no
one gives a [ __ ] about them I don't know
I don't think the state of Florida has
bad sports fans they got [ __ ]
unbelievable college football the
Hurricanes the Seminoles who else they
got they got the Florida [ __ ] Gators
maybe if they're [ __ ] college sports
weren't so great and they they would
actually show up to a pro game I don't
know
other than in Tampa Tampa just sucks man
they got the Buccaneers right who've
just sucked every year about one why am
I still picking on them they were in the
rearview mirror congratulations what a
[ __ ] playoff series that was I'm just
by the way I'm just breaking balls by
the way for all you dumb [ __ ] who
actually take this seriously my bill
Burt hates Tampa
he doesn't like Vancouver now my teams
are playing you guys and my team is not
as good as your team so what I do is I
just trash your city and if you're dumb
enough to take the [ __ ] paint I get a
nice debate going because if you want to
argue facts all you had to do is a
lightning fan is just say well we
wouldn't know for you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
and then that would have been the end of
it but you were too stupid to do it you
sat there defending houseboats for some
unknown reason so anyways the Stanley
Cup Finals this year is this Boston
Bruins versus the Vancouver Canucks in
case you haven't figured that out and we
haven't wanted since 1972 and the
Vancouver Canucks have never won it so
if you ever wanted to get into hockey
this would be the series to watch
because the fans are gonna be
ridiculously excited because one group
of fans have been waiting for 39 years
and the other group have been waiting
their entire hockey lives all right so
predictions for this series I'm doing
exactly what I did the last time I'm
picking the other team and maybe I'll
jinx them I think once again the other
team has too much fire with Henriksen
Dean and whatever his [ __ ] brothers
name is Ryan Kesler and then they got
Luongo Luongo you can rattle though you
know
Kessler's just a pretty boy now you know
he took all his anger out of the game to
start the [ __ ] playoff series versus
the San Jose shoe Joe Thornton goes you
want to fight any and he didn't he
didn't do anything he just took the face
off skated away with his shredded j.crew
body you know it's like what are you
doing dude you playing hockey you're
trying to be an underwear model I don't
understand what you're doing Ryan Kesler
all right so but he is an American so I
do like that aspect of them the Sen
Dean's are actually direct descendants
of Nazi SS soldiers you know not not
just some [ __ ] regular guy who worked
in a [ __ ] warehouse and then he got
put in a guard tower a I'm just doing my
job I'm not I'm talking about people who
executed that horrific Final Solution
all right so you know if you're rooting
for the Canucks out there people you
you're you're saying thumbs up to the
Nazis I'm just I'm just putting that out
there just blowing the lid off that one
people know I think it's gonna be a
great [ __ ] series I got a feeling the
Bruins are gonna win Game one and just
scare the [ __ ] out of that little mining
town up there I really I really got a
feeling I got a feelin charas gonna
score a goal you know against all odds
cuz he loves taking a [ __ ] slappa
when there's no one in front of the net
from the [ __ ] red line and he loves
to shoot right at their pancreas too but
I got a feeling it's gonna [ __ ] get
in between his goddamn elbow and the
side and then Luongo is gonna get
rattled he's got to get pulled in the
second period Lucci just got to have a
goal to shut up all you Boston [ __ ] who
are trashing him you dumb [ __ ] shut
your faces how many stars are we gonna
run out of town because they have a bad
couple of weeks I guarantee you at the
end of the season
Jacques Laughlin whatever the [ __ ] his
name is he's gonna [ __ ] georgie
animal steal our [ __ ] coach for the
Bruins Claude Julien is gonna [ __ ]
say that Lou cheech's is has a lower
body injury that's what I'm guessing
all right he's just not gonna say it
because there's piece of shits out there
who would actually go after the injury
but I I don't know I think we're gonna
win we gotta win the Cup Oh would that
be glorious that would be enough to
knock me right out of my sobriety
yeah I went to a [ __ ] party yesterday
and I actually showed up with a rack of
Blue Moon and handed it over and I
watched other people drink it and I was
just I really questioned my citizens
ship at that point like him I am I still
a citizen of this country that I just
[ __ ] did that this is how bad I want
to drink people I actually got into a
conversation about booze at this party
and somebody brought up Fredericksburg
Texas which is an hour and a half
outside of Austin Texas and evidently
it's an all-german town speaking of
Nazis okay now I don't know if you guys
realize this but I'm actually mostly
German I mentioned this before that's
why I have a jawline and I don't have
that 100% Irish potato face okay
I don't look like I I [ __ ] woke up
face down in a plate of [ __ ] mashed
potatoes like a lot of my Irish brothers
do okay I don't look like that I don't
look like you know I never knew my dad
because he got so drunk and he fell
face-first into his shepherd's pie and
is that actually English I don't [ __ ]
know anyway so let's plow ahead here so
there's this town called Fredericksburg
which is actually my middle name William
Fredericksburg burr I don't know if you
guys ever knew that and it's this all
German town and evidently when you drive
into town it was like one one [ __ ]
Street Main Street right and this way it
was described to me at the party
you know I barely was listening I was
just staring at the bubbles and the
guy's beer that's how bad I want to
drink now and the first half of it is a
bunch of antiques for though and the
second half though is just a bunch of
Oktoberfest type bars and I was thinking
like god dammit I want to go to that
town and drink out of one of those big
things we got to press it down with your
thumb and have the little [ __ ] crown
open up whatever the beer stein that's
how bad I want to drink now people so I
want to ask people people people of the
podcasting world who are listening to
this thing
what's what's the deal with Roseburg
Texas I want to know is it where
the trip bum in Austin what am I gonna
go down under the ad c-section again
down there I've done that a zillion
times I want to drive up to
Fredericksburg get absolutely shit-faced
and then drive home drunk back to Austin
get pulled over by some [ __ ] goddamn
cop and a horse you understand what
stage you're in this Texas don't mess
with Texas then I like I know how to
sweet talk my way out of that right
I just unbuttoned a couple of buttons
from my button-down show off a little
bit of red chest air and I just start
complimenting as his sidearm is that a
six-shooter you know what it is there's
six Huard I could put this on eBay and
get over a hundred grand for it but I
got it from my daddy you got it from his
daddy daddy is drive away then I
mentioned we have a donation button on
the mm podcast.com did I mention that I
always forget to mention that so just
donate whatever the [ __ ] you can donate
and I swear to God if you guys donate
this week I will i will donate five
dollars towards the United Nations fund
for curing the common cold do you know
the common cold doesn't kill over seven
million people every year do you realize
that but it makes over four billion
people
unbelievably uncomfortable and in some
extreme cases even in the month of May
so please give $1 give seven do whatever
you want to [ __ ] do oh by the way I'm
gonna be on the NHL live today
NHL live at 2:10 p.m. Pacific time
they're gonna be calling me on my cell
phone and they're gonna be a do what do
you think about the playoffs I can't
wait I cannot wait all right last week I
told you that's I read that story about
that dead [ __ ] douche
who brought in the ringer wasn't playing
this guy's kid and then when he
complained the parent complained you
know they kept the kid on the bench and
then the next year his kids on another
team and then he's playing against this
douche coach and at the end of the game
his kid didn't shake his hand and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] went to the goddamn league
and now is saying that this kid has to
shake hands
so the dads like what do i do what do I
do so I was trying to think of a kunti
way for this kid something he could do
to this guy so this is a solution summer
came up with said tell that kid to shake
that coach's hand for an awkwardly long
time I actually really like this idea
holding on when the coach tries to pull
his hand away and the whole time smiling
maybe throw a wink in there too you know
a passive-aggressive [ __ ] you love the
podcast bill I think that's great
I would actually clasp it with both
hands like you just signed some sort of
monumental peace treaty like do you know
it'd be great have have it have the did
his dad come down do you remember when
and when Jimmy Carter got was a Nam war
Sadat instead beggin Guy to shake hands
sign a peace treaty between Egypt and
Israel or something like that and they
both shook hands and then Jimmy Carter
made it like a handshake sandwich with
musing his hands as the bunts standing
basically perpendicular to them so I
think that that's what should happen
I think he should shake the guy's hand
clasp it with both hands and then you
hire a Jimmy Carter look-alike to
[ __ ] sit there and you just smile and
you don't let go until that guy finally
pulls his hands-free and you never stop
smiling and you never stop looking in
the guy's eye how's that I like that you
guys like that solution I do does
anybody else have any more stories about
that that seems to be an overwhelming
not overwhelming that's the wrong word
Jesus bill Jesus Christ the whole
podcast was going great and then what
you do you picked the wrong [ __ ] word
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
read the goddamn copy
did I ever tell you guys you guys always
think that this show is improvised it
isn't I actually write it out and I
spent $15,000 on my own
professional-grade camera and
teleprompter right now I'm reading all
of this including this right now it's
just scrolling right now you know that
whole I'm bad at reading out loud is
it's all just an act
anyways does anybody else have any
stories about that that type of behavior
rather than overwhelming I know it's a
reoccurring theme that's what I was
trying to say you know where somebody
becomes a coach and you know they're
getting to live out this Vince Lombardi
fantasy and then they start thinking
well I sucked as an athlete or I wasn't
good enough to make it to the pros and
then when they start coaching just
immediately that competitive thing kicks
in again and they forget that they're
coaching a bunch of [ __ ]
eight-year-olds and they start walking
around like [ __ ] Mike Ditka you know
chewing gum like they just got done
finishing a [ __ ] eight ball of coke
in case you thought I was talking about
pool I had to say of coke alright I'm
sorry people a little congested does
anybody else have any stories of that I
actually I had good coaches when I was
growing up except for my football coach
I remember used to kick me in my [ __ ]
legs I only played one year of football
what parents didn't like because I came
home with all these bruises and they
showed up at practice and they saw the
coach kicking me in my legs I remember I
used to move my when you were doing leg
lifts because that's what you want third
graders to do leg lifts to make sure
they get that 12 pack so we're doing
these leg lifts and you know whenever
your legs would come down he'd come over
and kick you in the side and give you
like a charley horse so I used to move
my five pads over the open to the side
this was the 70s people when you could
kick kids not only could you kick them
you can kick them in front of their
parents
it was [ __ ] great does anybody have
any stories it's just some some coaches
just going totally over the top here's a
new sound for you guys see if you guys
can guess what this sound is alright and
it's not me blowing my nose on the mic
what was that what was that noise you
hear that that might sound like me
wiping up my mustache I'm playing hockey
tomorrow and I wear a full [ __ ]
shield and I have a runny nose do you
understand what I'm gonna look like I'm
gonna be looking like I'm [ __ ] almost
at the summit of Mount Everest
by-the-bye my second shift there's that
icicles in your mustache what is going
on no it's just not all right now that I
got rid of the ladies on the podcast
speaking of ladies there's there's a
little downtime between the eastern and
western conference finals and the finals
in the Stanley Cup so I had four [ __ ]
days of oh my god how am I gonna fill up
the time and I don't know what happened
I put on ESPN and I've somehow got into
the lady softball [ __ ] World Series I
love it I absolutely love it I want to
face one of those [ __ ] pitchers you
got you know a lot a lot of guys out
there they laugh at that [ __ ] gun throw
it I'd [ __ ] I'd [ __ ] put it in the
cheap sheets if I ever [ __ ] the dead
giant goddamn ball first of all they
pitch the ball from like four feet away
and it comes underhand cuz they don't
think and they do it so fast it looks
like that's coming right out of that
baby maker you know like some sort of
[ __ ] nolan ryan meet some hoary
stripper you know you know the ones that
shoot the ping pongs out of their [ __ ]
this is looks like the softball is just
coming at this weird [ __ ] angle I
would love to do it because their ball
parks are really small so you so if you
actually made contact they pitch it so
fast it's going over the goddamn wall
and then you get to run around you get
to run around the bases but you don't
get it you know you're not going to get
winded because I think it's like 45 feet
to each base it's ridiculous basically
if there's no leading I think in women's
softball because once you take a lead
you're basically
second base or all you have to do is
just you know fall down you're safe at
second actually there is leading all
right before some [ __ ] Bulldog of a
woman [ __ ] starts giving me [ __ ]
about it I understand and dude speaking
of roids okay if you're gonna tell me
those women in ladies softball like this
it's just uh there's enough women built
like that to fill up [ __ ] like nine
different teams I'm not buying it okay
those girls I'm telling you right now
would run me the [ __ ] over not a damp
batteries ran out again and the memory
was full I don't what the [ __ ] happened
son of a [ __ ]
alright what the [ __ ] was that I'm
talking about those goddamn softball
ladies I'm telling you man those girls
with if they did the old Packers sweep
pitched it out to any one of them but
they'd [ __ ] they could run over Ray
Lewis but I'm telling you it's a great
goddamn sport and you know what it only
took a couple of seconds for you to
listen to me you know go from what I was
just talking about to what I'm talking
about right now but in my world it was
like five minutes and I can't remember
what the [ __ ] I was talking about so
that's going away oh it's so frustrating
I was really enjoying what he was saying
about those [ __ ] goddamn Bulldogs who
play [ __ ] softball - Lee nut Bulldogs
are something were a couple they're kind
of cute you know I like some [ __ ]
thick thighs I'll take it down you know
even with that grease under your eyes
Jesus all right
by the way we have a new video everybody
we have new video up on the MM
podcast.com member uh not last week but
the week before I was hyping the cage
vs. cons MMA event where they have cops
fighting ex-cons MMA style in the
Octagon at the LA sport's arena
well the Monday morning podcasts brand
new man in the street Jason lawhead
Jason lawhead who has his own sports
podcast with Joe bartnik and
John campanero Cap'n Dara is in the name
of the podcast is called men are talking
so anyways he was out there he covered
the invent for us with Sam Tripoli
another hilarious comedian and they made
a really great video if you want to see
what it was like which looked like it
was a [ __ ] great time
definitely the crowd was way more for
the cons then was for the cops and a lot
of tattoos were gotten a lot of weed was
smoked and I think you guys ought to
check it out it's a great video it's on
the MM podcast.com so after you're done
hitting the donation button right on the
right hand side right underneath the
Facebook [ __ ] icons check out that
video also I did I got another video
it's gonna be up later on this week I
did another one of my famous internet
tours of a city I did a tour of new New
York City that's gonna be up and I
actually ran into somebody not to get
all Hollywood on you I'm not gonna name
a name but I was out at an Italian
restaurant and as I was walking out
there was somebody famous
sitting there who hosts a talk show and
I and it wasn't Conan and it wasn't that
guy from Scotland um and I said hey
what's up to him and he mentioned that
he saw my feet [ __ ] watch the one
that I did the tour of LA I got a big
kick out of that don't look at the
goddamn internet famous people are on
the internet too I didn't realize that I
always thought like famous people that
are on TV so they they don't they don't
watch it they like read books or you
know go out and go buy like a [ __ ]
Ferrari or something it's always just
blowing my mind but whatever we got we
got this great video up there the cage
versus cons and I'm gonna have one tour
of New York City my tour of New York
City which I did when I was just
starting to catch this cold that was in
a miserable [ __ ] mood so it might
come off a little more angrier than
usual but it seems like a lot of you
guys enjoy that [ __ ] so definitely check
that out on a mmm podcast calm the
official podcast page of the Monday
morning podcast sorry we have 45 minutes
in people you know what that means that
means I got 15 minutes to go so
it's gotta be time for the advice
section and if I was actually if I had
some sort of production quality on this
we would have gone into some music right
there it's time for advice with your
host Billy Burr and I'm ripping off this
melody from somebody else all right dear
bill I am 34 years old and I've been
married to Linda @gz he names a name
right out of the gate oh the lovely Nia
comes walking in right as I'm about
ready to do advice what are the odds of
that once you'll grab yourself a
microphone it's in the closet my closet
all right and don't go snooping around
in there I got some fucking-a criminais
ting evidence in there god damn [ __ ]
broads can't ever keep their faces out
of your [ __ ] let me see if I can put
this in here here we go we're gonna get
this going right here anyways well I'm
reading the first one without you I'm 34
years old and been married to Linda my
wife for about five years
we met on an online dating website is
that amazing they met online and they've
already been married for five years how
long is the internet been around isn't
that fits this really phenomenal
starting to feel old Jesus Christ can
you tell I hit pause again people
[ __ ] [ __ ] what am I doing here all
right here we go
dear bill I'm 34 years old Mary said
that [ __ ] he's been online for [ __ ]
five goddamn years um we met on an
online dating website immediately felt a
special bond we dated for three years
but I knew she was the one wait a minute
no did I read this last week oh yeah I
read this one last week I'm on the wrong
[ __ ] page oh Jesus Oh Vijay hang on a
second all right where the [ __ ] are we
all right advice dear bill I've got a
few shitty things going on in my life
right now that I need to vent about also
I would like to hear your advice okay
you guys don't need to have [ __ ]
intros like that just ask me the advice
because then I'll read them and sound
like a [ __ ] in first things first I live
in South Carolina
and I think you can guess that that
pretty much blows I'm 22 years old and I
just graduated from college with a
degree in psychology my job outlook is
pretty bleak right now and I just got
laid off from my shitty delivery job
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] is going on
in this country this dude's has a degree
in psychology and he's delivering
[ __ ] Entenmann's Cakes to
supermarkets and he gets laid off
because I must have applied for at least
30 jobs at this point and I've stopped
applying for the ones that I'm under
qualified for and I've started sorry and
I'm still unemployed I don't understand
why the access of entry into the
restaurant industry is so [ __ ] high I
can't even get a job serving because
they keep telling me we only hire people
with two years of experience yeah well
it's the law it's the laws of supply and
demand you know if we weren't in the
middle of a recession you can walk in
there with a coming out of prison then
they'd let you work the goddamn mesquite
grill yeah I worked in a restaurant
there's a bunch of [ __ ] drug guys
sweet it was such a good economy it was
like 1987 wait a second that was right
after Black Monday I don't know maybe
was a south I have no idea I worked at
this place called the sable cafe in Cary
North Carolina way back in the day and
we used to have this douche who you see
came in he was on work release he was in
prison and they would let him out so he
could wash dishes and work his way back
now watch this he actually worked the
[ __ ] cooking line he was above me
right I was a busboy slash grill chef
slash dishwasher because the restaurant
was slowly going on a business in this
flash hottie as as people as people
gradually gradually quit they would
[ __ ] they would just give me their
jobs and an extra 50 cents an hour I was
like wow I'm raking in the dough cuz I
sucked at math I didn't realize that
they were paying me 350 an hour in a
grill guy five dollars an hour so they
went from paying 850 an hour but two
guys to paying me four dollars an hour
for [ __ ] Emma's dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] so
anyways and that this douche used to
come in
I remember one time I came walking in
the back I'm doing three [ __ ] jobs we
were slammed and I said ah my go we're
out of glasses the [ __ ] we're out of
glasses
then this guy work-release goes well why
don't you wash some ah a novel idea
that's what he said like he was just
[ __ ] in Renaissance man really really
there's Shawshank the [ __ ] are you doing
after work huh
[ __ ] carving of God there hey watch
all the steak knives make sure Conti
over here doesn't take him back with
your felon beard you're this stupid
[ __ ] Allman Brothers facial hair five
[ __ ] [ __ ] it still bugs me cuz I
didn't say anything to him because I got
intimidated even though I thought I
could take the guy was like this guy's
been in prison you know he's gonna beat
me up and then rape me [ __ ] I think
I'll wash some glasses
so anyways um he goes if I can struggle
through four years of school then I
think I can get the hang of slinging
tater skins and onion rings in a few
weeks
what is what is there to learn all these
guys trying to get a cooking job well
good whatever a serving job well I
thought he meant like being a waiter but
now it sounds like yakking about
actually cooking yeah dude you can't
learn on the job at a restaurant no you
always was that underdog I'm sorry
they're not coming really he's uh
nobody's talking about cooking he's not
because I thought he said he was having
a hard time being here I was a server
cuz that you can learn in like two
seconds no that's what that's what he
said but now I'm Sonny's talking about
slinging tater skins and onion rings I
think he just means serving it slinging
doesn't slinging mean yeah but wasn't
didn't you say earlier that he disagree
with what is that alerting let me defect
this what is there to learn in the
second year of restaurant experience
that you can't get in the first year
even the first six months since I agree
with how in the hell am I supposed to
get a job I'm also being cut out from
financial support of my family who
helped put me through school if I can't
start paying bills and I'm gonna have to
move back in with my parents in a shitty
small town that is about an hour away
from the city I live in job outlook
there is even worse and I would hate to
move away from my friends and girlfriend
me and my girl don't live together but
she's offered a lot of needed support
and most importantly she supports me
pursuing comedy it's my dream to become
a comedian and I can only go so far
while I live in South Carolina no what
is it that he can only go so far living
in South Carolina yeah the [ __ ] oh you
becoming the next goddamn Cable Guy dude
there's people this I've guarantee you
in South Carolina
there's a guy there who's the king of
South Carolina and we've never heard of
him
every state I've been there yeah and
they [ __ ] make six figures a year I'm
not I understand what he's saying
obviously doesn't want to be the king of
South Carolina what Skinner and movies
and TVs come and nationally headlining
Act I understand what you're saying but
I'm just saying you can make [ __ ]
money there there is money to be made
with those drunk [ __ ] idiots there
all you got to do just do a Ric Flair
impression that'll be a closing bit
you'll be fine
I would he lives out there I would like
to move to New York City but won't be
able to do that if I'm not able to save
up money and I definitely won't be able
to do that anytime soon because I am
awaiting a trial for a DUI I got back he
was getting like unravel more and more
every sentence becomes something else
that's why country songs are so sad
these people live it I love my girls
vagina and I can't get a job washing
dishes did you just run Carolina buddy
you wife and I don't know why cuz the
cop was even drunker than me and the
song should be called I know I'm not Ric
Flair coz I know I ain't Ric Flair and I
know I don't bleach my hair but I got a
dream and would you help me get your
hand off you god I'm starting to get
scared that run with hair all right go
[ __ ] yourselves anyways the trial is
this September and if I lose my license
I will only be set further back for my
goals yeah you think I'm trying - not to
mention I'm growing weed in my apartment
it's a one bedroom with bay windows and
I think my neighbors
starting to catch on I am trying to hone
my skills here
no oh Jesus somebody went out late last
night I'm trying to hone my skills here
but I can't afford to keep driving to
open mics that are at at least an hour
way across the state North Carolina by
the way I've stopped drinking
irresponsibly and I'm sorry that this
email ran a little long respectfully so
itself get Aloha the politeness of the
South respectful yeah
phrase when those Plantation Kentucky
Fried Chicken ties on holding onto his
lapels get you with the politeness oh
that's the that's you know that's
masking so much yeah you know what that
is that's called the old it's called the
old Stonewall Jackson the old Stonewall
Jackson come in I surely would like to
help you don't you look pretty today hey
I ain't trying to be disrespectful right
then you [ __ ] turn the corner we tell
you something about that boy that Boyd
[ __ ] mud if he thought a rock was under
snake whoa what's going on with the
thing here that boy [ __ ] rock if
thought of snake was under it so what is
what is he he's asking me how the [ __ ]
he gets out of all this bad [ __ ] all
right you live in South Carolina let's
let's recap shall we there's a South
Carolina can't get a job slinging
[ __ ] tater tots - [ __ ] fatties who
are wearing overalls and somehow the
crack of their ass is still hanging out
of it he got a DUI he's gonna have to
move back home with his parents an hour
away where the job [ __ ] is even worse
than it is where he is right now and he
got Jesus Christ and he wants to live
his dream I mean I always see one
solution here other than hitting the
lottery you got to start dealing weed I
mean yeah right South Carolina can he
grow some - Becky
yeah just let's just start sowing wacky
tabacky
yeah wait wait wait there's something
going on with this [ __ ] to sound here
Jesus Christ see people this is why I
need you to hit the donation' button we
here at billboard PBS here I think I
need a new mixer or some new wires
didn't they say something about being a
psychology major or something aren't you
supposed to do some sort of internship
at after you do school and he does not
even for that get entry into a job he
doesn't want to do that this guy wants
to be a comedian so what do you want to
be yeah yeah so so what he needs he
needs some sort of hustle to get him out
of this [ __ ] all right dude this this
will make you feel better
guess what happened to me right before I
became a stand-up comedian I lost my
license for drinking and driving and I
didn't get I didn't get started are the
batteries going low on this thing hello
help
hello there we go oh the thing got a
plot that sounded badass when it starts
to come out take me
sorry alright here we go
I'm back what did I just hit a [ __ ]
button here now this other things lit up
which was never lit up before oh you
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright let's let's wrap
this thing up this is what you got to do
dude you got it why you got to get
through your DUI and I don't know what
to tell you man you gotta somehow try
and find a [ __ ] job [ __ ] I lived at
home with my parents I had a day job and
then I and I did comedy at night and I
saved every [ __ ] dime
I drove a piece-of-shit car and when it
died rather than get a new one I just
had him throw a new engine in my old one
so I only went like 1500 in debt rather
than 15 grand that's what I did so
listen if you want to be a [ __ ]
comedian you want it bad enough you're
gonna figure out how to do it you're in
a hell of a situation there you got to
get a [ __ ] job dude I would open take
any [ __ ] job you can take landscaping
anything you can do get through this
[ __ ] DUI horseshit and despite the
fact that you work all day you still got
to go out and you still have to do those
open mics you got to do it and as hard
as it's gonna be it's gonna it's gonna
make you tough and that's what you gotta
be to make it in the world you got to be
tough you got to get up but you know
what you've been knocked on your ass you
flat on the back flat on your back and
you got to get up alright the refs over
you right now six seven most people just
lay there I'm gonna go [ __ ] lay
between my mom's titties and just say I
quit in life you're not gonna do that
are you you're gonna pick yourself up
you should've seen the look see this
baby now trying to inspire him this kid
is in a [ __ ] hole yeah but he can get
out of it he's got a second up how would
you get outside how would you get out of
it I would do like you said I'd have to
take any job that I could get but I'm
subject so maybe I could get no I was
thinking babysitting you pervert
you'd [ __ ] yourself out no I wouldn't
Wow what I want
my name is Nia buh-buh-buh-buh and I got
some high-heeled doo-doo-doo-doo what's
the [ __ ] hit this you wouldn't sell
your ass you know if you had to sell
your ass if you had to do it if you had
Nene to become a lady of the evening
Oh of the evening I had to do it I
wouldn't go out on the street that's for
sure how would you do it I would set up
like a website or something I'd be one
of those high-class broads oh yeah I
meet you in like the lobby of a hotel
I'd be make it classy what would be the
theme song your website dude no that's I
would I would be interested in that
unless if you went but if you had that
song and you were wearing a veil that
would freak me out why would I wear a
veil just that's what that song just
made me think of this veil and you're
doing this really bad dance and it just
cancels out your hotness yeah better you
ever had the guys you ever had that you
ever girl just do something so weird it
cancels out like how good-looking she is
maybe a laugh like because she's so
drunk I was thinking more like hammer
toes coming out of some [ __ ] you know
pair of sexy shoes when you're gonna get
the shoes with the red sole on it so you
can make all those other [ __ ] joke
when you buy me a pair [ __ ] your
birthday is coming up yes it is and I
can tell you right now well I don't know
what you're getting but I can tell you
what you're not getting what do you mean
you don't know overpriced horse shoes
yeah you know I do it last second you've
seen the birthday cards they give you aa
or the one I gave you last year that had
to do we had to do with golf and I just
sort of scribbled it out they were out
of birthday cards they didn't have the
purse I went to the place didn't ever
probably didn't ask for it right anyway
they asked for a write first could I
have are you lying
good by lying about what did you
actually get
surprise no you know what the reality is
you know I never went there what what is
wrong with you no you weren't
yes I was I'm still sick I've been
coughing and blowing in the head that's
well you know what I can tell you where
to go in LA to get it we're getting
we're gonna go I care good yeah you know
why cuz you're exposing the spoiled
little brat that you are this is up mult
is that mine because I went out I I
would buy you stuff that you wanted
thinking that that would shut you up not
why y'all got it
why yeah you know I love most about you
is you sure that's what I like best
about you when you're not running you
yeah and you just [ __ ] rubbing my
head as I watch sports that's what I
like that's all I need out of you Nene
all those stupid shows where they go a
[ __ ] way to a man's heart is through
his stomach no it isn't shut your trap
rub my head as I'm watching the game in
order a pizza right then and now the end
of the night when I could hear the night
a little sexual cooking for you you love
that I do love it then you tell me when
I wasn't here for a couple days you felt
like at a loss because you're so
dependent on me ridiculous I mean you
were walking around the apartment like
oh would you I did it was pathetic
you know you know I felt like the male
Stepford wife I know how to pay bills
you take that back lady I take it back
I'm just [ __ ] with you so I I don't
know I don't know how to use Dawn a cook
I used to cook [ __ ] I there was there
was food and I would cook it and it
would make it a taste delicious I'm back
in the day I made lasagna was great yeah
[ __ ] make the salmon too and that I
used to make that I had I had the beef
stew a big piece of Bailey set it and
forget it to make a rotisserie style
chicken set it and forget it yeah
underrated underrated that thing I don't
know I think I threw that thing out that
why because with those big weird rubber
gloves
handle the chicken those things weren't
like the [ __ ] sex offender is so
[ __ ] creepy they came with these
these big rubber gloves that they didn't
move that was a thing they were like
they were like form to some murderers
hands and you just had to slip your
hands into because they're so worried
about getting you getting burned they
didn't want to get soup and all the way
up to the elbows like Jackie Kennedy but
they were these big [ __ ] Herman
Munster gloves oh and they were doing
with this off-white yeah they look worse
color they look filthy before we even
got him but getting back to the Senate
and forget it that's right studio on
it's a joke that thing was the [ __ ] that
thing I made a pretty good chicken I
made a great chicken yeah they had it
down and it came out was golden brown
and he had [ __ ] lunch meat for the
[ __ ] week right yelling that suck was
on top the way they claimed the heat
would somehow steam the vegetables that
[ __ ] didn't work so I took out my wok
and that was it hey by the way how sweet
is that guitar I bought it's beautiful
Miley I bought the best goddamn guitar I
absolutely and that's all I've been
doing for less you know I had I had that
brutal couple weeks right now yeah I was
on [ __ ] six flights in 15 days I
caught a cold yeah I caught a cold I did
those two episodes of Glee yeah right
and the one episode sorry shot in two
days and then and I was did DC and I did
New York in the middle of that so every
once in a while I will actually go out
and I'll spend a little money on myself
and I bought a Gibson SG that is white
left-handed white with the black pickup
not black pickup the black pickguard and
this thing sounds so [ __ ] good even
even I sound good on it playing that
Aerosmith this week seasons of weather
remember you came in and all of a sudden
you know you were hypnotized by it you
don't marry that boy I yeah whatever
but having a good time I'm gonna having
a good time with it so uh anyways that
is it that's the podcast for this week
I got who I want to thank Jason lawhead
and Sam Tripoli Nia you got to see that
video
you got my head oh my god it's hilarious
things in my head is an incredible
person yeah he has an incredible podcast
with Joe Barton it called men are
talking the two of them on the podcast
yeah oh my god all right I have together
these are the two guys that if you know
if you want if you're gonna go out
drinking or if you just want to [ __ ]
hang out with these guys that they are
throwbacks old-school guy guys guys
these are the guys when I go to the Rose
Bowl every year these are the guys your
partners in crime partners in crime
these are the guys I stumble into the
Rose Bowl with with Cuban cigars and
then people scream at us and we have a
great [ __ ] time yeah so that's up on
the mmm podcast calm if you want to
donate we really appreciate it and we're
gonna be doing some more video
definitely and starting to add those you
can only see that exclusively on the mmm
podcast com I think I've said that
enough
okay so upcoming dates upcoming dates
for mr. burr only the [ __ ] Fisher
website okay billboard.com I'm gonna be
at the Chicago Theatre on June 15th
doing one of those anti social network
tours with the wonderful Jim nor Norton
the fabulous Jim Breuer and the always
adorable Dave Attell Dave Attell is a
sweetheart of a guy I realized it we
went when we went and we visited those
troops at the the Pentagon the wounded
warriors who visit these soldiers you
know we didn't know what to say or
whatever dude dave was in his [ __ ]
element really he [ __ ] lit up and was
going to I just followed his lead and it
was awesome and like he yet that's so
good you guys are that oh and it's
Memorial Day tomorrow yeah yeah no we're
what are we doing sitting there
sweatpants of them on our bed you know
should we go to a parade or something
all right and on June 29th I'm doing the
this very special one here this is the
greg Giraldo benefit at The Wiltern
theater all proceeds go to his wife
kids and uh you know definitely people
come out to that yeah that's that's a
huge one definitely if you're gonna be
gonna do anything even if you're in
Chicago drive out the [ __ ] LA for
that one that's right and what else
real quick I have the pair these are
more antisocial Network dates on July
1st I'm at the Paramount Theater in
Seattle Washington just south of that
adorable mining town Vancouver and then
on the 3rd I'm gonna be in Vegas Oh
pearl theater Palms Resort Casino oh and
guess who's not going no I'm coming no
you're not fourth of July is coming out
I want the world to know you go [ __ ]
yourself you're staying home you only
support me he when I go to good cities
why don't you wonder why would I need
you when I go to Tampa how come you
don't come out for that one I came out
to Florida with you ones on Miami all
right you know what we're becoming like
Donny and Marie right now and I'm really
[ __ ] getting douche chills I gotta
get off this all right that's the
podcast for this week that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you next week
and I don't know
grab your lady's titties from me all
right that's it
that's it I'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you